thank you
we don't want to get too far behind
today so why don't we go ahead and get
going I apologize we don't have full
attendance for you Senator but we'll at
least get started I see these bills
aren't nearly as exciting as yesterday's
bills
title is throwing us off because we have
no idea what it means so that's the time
being 9 35 I will now open the public
hearing on Senate Bill 190 and recognize
the prime sponsor Senator Tim Lang thank
you for joining us thank you very much
uh Madam chair it feels like just
yesterday I was here
um
so uh Advanced deposit wagering it's
horse racing in simple terms it's horse
racing
um there was some confusion in the
lottery so this bill is brought at the
behest of the New Hampshire lottery as
well as the New Hampshire Attorney
General's office there was some
confusion as to whether or not uh say
when the Kentucky Derby is running and
you pick up the phone and you call and
place a bet on a horse whether that was
legal or not
um and it's it there's a there's a
provision it's called we'll see if I can
find there's a federal provision that
allows it's the interstate horse racing
Act of 17 of 1978 which legalizes at a
federal level that Interstate action but
at the state level we have a little bit
weird rules with charitable gaming
online gaming and those kind of things
and so the question was whether or not
it was legal in New Hampshire and so
when the lottery went to
um the Attorney General's office and
asked for a legal opinion basically the
Attorney General General said well we're
not sure and they weren't sure whether
it was legal or not so they asked us to
submit a bill to make it clear that
we're in compliance with the interstate
horse racing gaming act and it is a
legal function within the state of New
Hampshire that's the short version of
the bill there are some other things in
here that just provide consumer
protections bonding for the gaming
operators as well as things like cyber
security requirements and that kind of
stuff for these online for these uh
horse racing outfits that are going to
be working in New Hampshire
there are a lot smarter people behind me
that probably can answer detailed
questions but if you have questions
about the words on the bill I can
is this a phone app what are we talking
about so it's it's a it's a combination
of both again like a lot of horse racing
is done literally by phone you know call
into you know Churchill Downs and place
your bet for the Kentucky Derby right
and so you can have an account put in
your account make and make the BET and
the question was again whether that was
legal it also involves a gaming app so
you can twin spiers or Churchill Downs
uh their app
um it also legalizes that as an
interstate action that goes on as well
so that's what that Interstate horse
racing Act of 1978 allows for interstate
commerce like including horse racing so
this just clarifies that New Hampshire
says yeah it's legal in New Hampshire
too and not in violation of one of our
thank you Senator other would you take
questions sure absolutely okay uh other
questions from the committee
uh representative again
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking my question
um
is there a limit on um
how large these deposits are
so again I I defer to Senator Bragdon
over here the former Senate President
who's going to be testifying who has a
lot more detail about the inner
operations of how things like Churchill
Downs works all right thank you
yes representative Orson thank you madam
chair and thanks for taking my question
so
Advance deposit account wagering so
somebody has an account on file like an
e-account and so they can place bets at
any time but even during the race
again I'd defer that to Mr Bragdon I'm
not an expert in horse racing by any
stretch of the imagination again I
brought this because of lotteries
statement the fact that it was
questionable whether or not it was legal
or not and so we wanted to make it
absolutely clear in statue that it was a
legal activity and we were in compliance
with the interstate horse racing Act of
1978. okay very good let's follow up
and so I guess it's just the word event
so all the advanced means is the money's
on file somewhere right again usually
it's again you open an account you may
deposit some money in and then you use
that money for your betting and then you
either renew it with more money if you
lose and if you don't lose then you get
to continue to use the money or withdraw
it for your bank account very good thank
you
uh just because of that does this bill
go to Commerce at all or no this is just
this bill it did not in the in the house
in the Senate okay thank you
uh representative thank you madam chair
thank you senator for taking my question
I missed the very beginning and you
might have just touched on it you filed
this legislation at at whose request
sorry both the New Hampshire lottery as
well as the Attorney General's office
there was a question on legality and we
wanted to clear clarify the legality
a question on the legality can you
expand on that okay sure so New
Hampshire are even our horse racing um
language is pretty Antiquated
um and so it didn't anticipate whether
you could pick up the phone and call or
whether you could
um place a bet online uh using an app
um it didn't clarify that we have brick
and mortar type locations in New
Hampshire I think there's two or three
that allow for simulcast and horse
betting races at Brick and Mortar but
there was nothing to find so we
legalized horse betting uh betting on
horse races but we didn't have a an
off-site mechanism for it and yet the
federal government did allow for that
follow okay and this is probably better
for legal counsel for lottery but you
had mentioned the app TwinSpires that's
one of the apps I know about there's
several of them and you can ask again
I'm not an expert by any stretch I file
this bill again at the request of
Lottery and are you aware that that app
has been in use in the state of New
Hampshire
I know maybe illegally for decades again
I know that and that's why the question
came up was that the app was in use and
the question came forward whether or not
it was legal or not and there was an
inconclusive uh determination and so
we're trying to make it a conclusive
determination
thank you very much senator okay the
chair will now recognize I'm sorry madam
chair one more thing please so you're
going to have
um so uh Senator Bragdon is going to be
giving you some ideas for change that
have been vetted through Lottery and I
know that and if the committee were to
adopt these changes the Senate ways it
means committee would concur with those
adoptions of changes okay it's clarified
language thank you for the heads up on
that uh we'll recognize Sean Thomas from
express bet
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee thank you very much for this
opportunity my name is Sean Thomas I'm
with Demers and praisal here in Concord
and here today representing express bit
in support of Senate Bill 190. let me
first tell you quickly about express bet
and then why we support this bill
express bet is an ADW or Advanced
deposit wagering or online horse
wagering provider and has been since
2002 it offers online horse betting so
you can make your picks and place your
bets at over 400 race tracks whether on
your computer your phone or other
electronic device and express bet is
completely dedicated to horse racing
that's all they do online horse betting
it's really a commitment they are
heavily invested in the technology and
in providing the industry's safest most
secure and most reliable experience and
that's really what this bill is all
about and why we ask for your support I
think the bill probably reads a little
more complicated than it actually is
online horse betting already takes place
in New Hampshire this wouldn't be an
expansion of gambling the question when
it comes to Senate Bill 190 is whether
the industry should continue unregulated
or whether it should be regulated and
licensed through lottery so I know it
seems unusual that we would support
regulation but we really view it as a
good thing one it clarifies the law you
heard there are you know there's some
there's some question there's a gray
area call it we currently operate under
federal law and pursuant to a
multi-jurisdictional license
um
in New Hampshire doesn't specifically
address that federal law and that's
really the gray area but we have
so that's so it clarifies the law that's
a good thing and two it really comes
down to and has to do a lot with
consumer protection
um and so I I guess what I'll say about
that is so expressbed is already
committed to providing a secure legal
experience but that should be guaranteed
to all New Hampshire residents whether
through express bet or another provider
and how this compares to other states so
we currently operate in 38 States in 22
we have a license and so it would be
great to add New Hampshire as number 23.
also a side note about the bill so this
is generally supported by industry
obviously by Lottery is that the request
of Lottery it came out of Senate Ways
and Means with unanimous ought to pass
recommendation recommendation past the
Senate on a Voice vote there was no
opposition in the Senate and I'm still
not aware of any opposition at this
point
um so again thank you very much for this
opportunity to to testify and I also
provided or passed up written testimony
with more information about express bet
and that's from Gene chabreira Express
vice president of Regulatory Affairs so
would you be open to questions from the
committee sure would awesome
questions from the committee
representative Giuseppe yeah just a
quick question have you
and do you at present have you been
taken online bets on horse racing since
2002. I believe that's correct yes okay
a super question how do you ensure
someone's over 18 how do you verify that
um so express bet uses a third party to
verify identity age residence
and that's really robust technology so
that that's a very important piece of
what we do
you know when the user comes when the
user
someone comes onto the app wants to use
the system that is the very first thing
that takes place we need to verify their
identity make sure they are who they say
they are
thank you very much other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much okay the chair will recognize
Peter Bragdon who is representing
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record Peter Bragdon
I'm a senior policy advisor at pretty
strategies here representing Churchill
Downs and a thing you may not know about
me is I for a number of years taught
high school math and one thing I learned
was you never hand out what you want to
deal with uh before you want to deal
with it because then people spend all
their time looking at it so um I with
great trepidation handout my my
suggestions before I actually say
anything but I'll get to that in a
moment so uh here today representing
Churchill Downs Churchill Downs is best
known uh and it's been mentioned earlier
today I was home with the Kentucky Derby
which is the longest continuously
running sporting event in America having
started in 1875 in the first Saturday in
may this may will be the 149th running
of the Kentucky Derby and fun fact the
Kentucky Derby and Churchill Downs was
started by the grandson of William Clark
of Lewis and Clark expedition Fame so at
trivia night at the bar
never know might win with that one so
Churchill Downs is a publicly traded
Corporation we have more than 30 race
tracks and Gaming facilities in more
than a dozen States including the
Chase's Poker Room in Salem as mentioned
before we have a twin spiers division
that offers Advanced deposit wagering
and live video from all major race
courses in the United States and abroad
including tracks from the United Kingdom
Sweden Japan New Zealand Australia and
South Africa
uh here this morning in support of
Senate Bill 190 with some suggested
changes to consider I would say that we
feel sb190 would give certainty and
predictability to the state's regulation
Advance deposit wagering as was
mentioned earlier there is some gray
area I guess it seems as to whether it's
legal or not
um or at least whether it's covered by
federal law or state law and we feel
it's best to get that resolved we do
operate in more than 30 States and it
would certainly be good to have the
regulatory structure clarified we do ask
the committee consider a few changes and
I didn't keep a copy of that for myself
but I believe the first one is to take
out the um maybe could I uh get a copy
foreign
oh yeah now I remember so uh the first
change is a relatively simple removing
uh some words so at the end of the last
sentence of a proposed new paragraph uh
22-c3 uh remove the everything after the
word chapter so on line 21 uh would
enter the word chapter and I put the
explanation there basically the goal of
this whole paragraph is to allow
evidence of Surety bonds used in other
jurisdictions to be allowed to be
submitted in New Hampshire as well one
of the goals is to make it so that uh
all the various vendors of ADW Services
aren't doing different things in every
single state so there's pretty much
everybody does it the same way uh except
this language about payments due to the
account holders is not something that I
believe appears in other states so it
would make it a little more difficult we
do believe however that the account
holders are still protected because if
you look at the bill on line 28 just a
little bit further down from that
um
the Lottery Commission will require a
plan of operation to be submitted that
has to be approved by the Lottery
Commission and line 28 says that that
plan of operation has to include
procedures to protect the security of
account holders accounts and their
information so we believe it's covered
by that and I will say that these have
all been run uh changed Auburn run by
Lottery who has approved them in Senator
Lang also indicated he would be
acceptable with them as well the second
suggests the change is to add some
language to uh paragraph F on page two
line
four and that deals with a financial
audit and as I mentioned before
Churchill Downs is a publicly traded
Corporation TwinSpires as a division uh
so there's a number of financial audits
that we already go through and submit to
the Securities and Exchange Commission
so we asked there was some gray area as
to whether that might be considered uh
suitable for f and we thought it'd be
better if it was clearly spelled out
that it would and again lotteries agreed
to that and then last but not least add
the words for cause uh onto that
paragraph five which appears on line
nine of page two the
um this involves the lottery revoking
the plan of operation so we just
requested that it before cause not that
we have any dispute with the Lottery
Commission or the folks at Lottery now
they've been uh very gracious and
flexible so don't anticipate a problem
but I'll say the lawyers pointed that
out so I'm not a lawyer so
um so those are the changes we would
suggest and
um there may be others that other
vendors have suggested but uh I'll speak
for these and I'm happy to answer any
questions that uh you only oh I'm sorry
one other thing I should mention is I
almost forgot this the line 12 on page
two uh and then I will say Lottery has
agreed with the changes I handed out to
you uh a lot I've not uh Lottery has not
agreed that I know I'm going to be
bringing this up have not agreed with
anything on that I'm about to say line
12 indicates that there'll be a a
revenue sharing if you will of 2.25
percent of everything all wagers
accepted uh we have a simulcast
provision in state law that has a
similar structure but the rate there is
only one and a quarter percent so in our
mind these are two different forms of
betting on horse races and maybe be
better if those two numbers were the
same but that's for you folks to to
consider
and having said that I'll be happy to
answer any questions you might have
though I will say people have uh made it
out like I'm an expert on horse racing
and can answer any questions that come
up I may not be able to
yes questions from the community and
welcome representative Stringham nice to
see you uh you too yes well thank you
for inviting me uh question on on your
amendment number two uh you say the
wagering provider is a subsidiary uh
would it be acceptable to say a wholly
owned subsidiary or rather than one
that's only partially owned by the
parent company
um I don't know enough to comment on
that uh but uh I can understand why that
might be a reasonable request on your
part uh secondly publicly traded company
um you know there's some publicly traded
companies and not not yours in
particular but uh they're just bulletin
boards there's not not the same degree
of public uh auditing and rigor uh would
it be acceptable to say publicly traded
company on a major Stock Exchange
I would think so okay thank you
representative Doucette did I see your
hand up
I'm Jan thank you for taking my question
um
I've got two questions one is how long
has TwinSpires been taking bets in New
Hampshire thank you for the question
represent I'm not sure how long I
understand it's been quite some time
although I will say Churchill uh
TwinSpires no longer operates in New
Hampshire as of last year as of last
year yeah partly due to the issue of the
gray area of regulatory and everything
else okay and during the time that they
were operating I know the the one
remaining license in the state to take
simulcast betting is the brook now and
they're paying 1.25 on gross wages uh
what did twin spies pay to the state of
New Hampshire during that time uh thank
you for the question represent I'm not
100 sure but I'm going to guess the
other questions from the committee yes
representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my questions so does Churchill
Downs plan to reimburse the state of New
Hampshire
for the operation at Randall legally for
a number of years I think uh thank you
for the question representative I think
the dispute is whether it ran illegally
or not and as pointed out by Senator
Lang the Attorney General's office
requested this specific statute so
there's a regular structure in place
um
it's uh
Advanced deposit wagering is permitted
by the interstate horse racing act and
there's nothing in New Hampshire statute
that uh prohibits it so in in our view
it was something that was allowed and
the state could tax it if they chose to
it was I you tapered off at the end
uh that the um it was allowed by federal
law wasn't proven by state law uh and if
the state had chosen to tax it then it
would have been taxable but at the time
I would just remind committee members we
are not here to debate people who are
testifying and we are definitely not
here to suggest motives or anything like
that so just be
professional please thank you
thank you so you may not be aware of it
but are you willing to look into it and
get back to us with an answer uh and
look into what I'm sorry whether or not
the operation was running illegally well
I can tell you uh The Churchill Downs
that doesn't mean it wasn't illegal
okay thank you that's you that's enough
thank you
thank you thank you uh
John good forty welcome to Ways and
Means from the New Hampshire Lottery
Commission
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is John Conforti I'm
the chief compliance officer for the New
Hampshire Lottery Commission
um thank you for
um having my testimony here today
um as Senator Lang indicated
um lawyer commission asked for this bill
to be put forward
um and the to give a little bit of
background on this and I know it's it's
been spoken about
um a bit
um Advanced positive wagering has been
going on for quite some time uh multiple
decades I believe and and primarily at
this point in time it's done online I
think traditionally there was the
ability to actually call into the track
have a we have an account uh on hand at
the track and be able to bet over the
phone and obviously as
um as we've gone into the era of
smartphones that has uh migrated to
online apps and several online apps are
currently operating in New Hampshire
um and have been for some time and um as
has been mentioned TwinSpires which is
uh probably the largest in the industry
was operating for quite some time in New
Hampshire and voluntarily ceased
operations in the fall of this year
after uh discussions with the Lottery
Commission and the Department of Justice
um to give a background on
the legality of this activity
um there is as was mentioned a federal
law the interstate horse racing act
which
um permits
um
this type of activity to happen across
state lines for example sports betting
cannot happen across state lines it has
to happen within the boundaries of each
particular state where it's either
authorized or not horse racing has broad
ability to cross state lines however
states have the ability to then either
approve of that activity or disapprove
of that activity so a number of these
operators operate in New Hampshire under
a license issued by the state of Oregon
um and and Oregon is the common state
for licensure for a number of them and
then the 50 states and territories
fall into sort of three different
buckets there are states that authorize
this activity specifically
and regulated and and uh and collect
money from it there are those that
strictly forbid it and then there's a
gray area in between
until now New Hampshire has laid in the
gray area and certainly the Lottery
Commission was concerned that some of
these activities may be in conflict with
some of our our gaming statutes we asked
the Department of Justice to take a look
at this and they were as Senator Lang
indicated and I don't speak for the
Department of Justice but I used to work
there I do not speak for them now and
when I worked there they didn't let me
speak for them so they certainly won't
do it now
um but there was you know essentially
there was an inconclusive decision and
ultimately with respect to Churchill
Downs and twin spiers there was a
voluntary decision made
to to exit the market while it remained
in the gray area until we could operate
in the white area this is this bill is
essentially what we're trying to do is
bring this in to regulate the state to
buy the state directly so that we're not
reliant on the regulations of Oregon or
the oversight of Oregon
um and certainly we want to make sure
that New Hampshire players are protected
that the best practices of the industry
in terms of protection of personal
account information responsible gaming
um and and making sure that Wagers are
protected and paid out properly uh is
all done in New Hampshire in in
accordance with New Hampshire rules so
that is why we asked for this to come
forward and we appreciate Senator Lang
uh taking that up for us one other thing
and then I'll certainly open up for
questions
um
Churchill Downs obviously brought
forward a number of uh revisions we do
not agree with the uh revision of the
tax structure or the mark the the um
the market share agreement that is in
there obviously it is different than the
um the rate that the tracks uh pay but
certainly different
um
different types of gaming are subject to
different structures all the time tracks
obviously have a significant investment
here in New Hampshire and significant uh
cost basis in terms of the Personnel
that they employ here
um and certainly that comes into effect
when we look at what the appropriate
market share agreement for New Hampshire
is but with respect to the other uh
changes that are suggested those have
been discussed not just with Churchill
Downs but with other members of the
industry and the Lottery Commission
feels comfortable with the language that
has been proposed and would endorse that
that change and then one last thing and
then I will stop talking and answer
questions
um I understand that some of the local
tracks May
um be concerned about the
differentiation in uh in rate that
because they also to advance the
positive wagering we do not want to set
up a situation where
um
local actors who are doing ADW are
treated differently I think that that
could lead to significant problems from
a legal perspective certainly Wagers at
the track will remain
um main subject to the same tax
um but we're asking that all ADW
activities whether it be done by
national companies or done by New
Hampshire companies be subject to this
new legislation if you were to pass it
so with that I'll end my remarks my I'm
sorry lengthy remarks
thank you very much a lot to learn uh
representative Platt I did not catch
what you do not agree with and perhaps
you could point out where it is on this
street uh so I do not have a copy of
that
it changes yes so that's those are the
changes they're asking for and then
obviously
they're yeah they're concerned about
that okay so it is uh page two line 12
the 2.25 they would like that reduced to
one and a quarter
um and that is the only change that we
might take us a minute if you could just
give us a second to absorb all that
fabulous information
[Laughter]
I apologize I tend to run on very long
and with a lot of words we're also
taking notes so sometimes it takes a
little bit
representative Doucette
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question also uh
what Mr bragden offered was a change to
the uh the bond at present
uh I know the one operator has to be
bonded would would Lottery be in
opposition to removing that Bond
so so representative set thank you for
the question I as I read the language
and as we agree to it it does not remove
the bonding requirement it makes the
bond applicable to the payments to the
state as opposed to
the accounts themselves the player
accounts themselves being bonded for the
player counts and that is similar to how
we do do it with tracks and with sports
betting right now essentially we protect
the player accounts by doing an overview
of we we ensure monthly that there's
enough money in the reserve account to
handle to cover all of the player
accounts so there is no need to bond on
that we did uh when we drafted this
language
um that was an oversight on our part
um we would not normally have gaming
bonds apply to player funds we again we
protect player funds through other means
representative Rushford yes thank you
madam chair and thank you for the coming
in today and I apologize that this was
mentioned earlier
um I was late myself but as I understand
this the the operations right now or in
a gray area no one's really sure what's
going on what's you know the legislation
would clearly Define the activity so
skipping to the the last page on the
fiscal note
um you're estimating or assuming there's
17 million dollars in this type of
wagering going on if this is
kind of off the Record uh and and no one
really knows what really is happening
how did you come up with these numbers
to assume that level of wagering so
thank you for the question
representative we we have had a very
robust conversation with the industry
and the industry's actually been quite
um receptive to regulation
um and these are these are discussions
that have happened over the last few
years along with our legal review with
the Department of Justice
um and so that number was based partly
on uh information that is known from
other states and doing a per capita
analysis but also from some direct
information that was provided by the
industry itself so we feel fairly
comfortable that that is a reasonable
effort at what is currently uh Happening
representative Janine
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um there's been there's been ongoing
concern that how do we prevent people
who are 18 years of age or younger than
18 from betting and I see that
um on line 23 the commission will not
license
um
a
Advanced deposit wagering um
place unless you have verified your
department is verified those methods
found how
how confident or how how is that done I
I think a third-party app was mentioned
before do you know what that 30 party
app is and how confident are we that
that works yes so
um
different uh operators use different
third parties so
um you know uh most of them actually use
multiple third parties to verify
um that an individual who signs up is a
um in a database and they they check
with their social security number their
date of birth their address and checking
against public uh the the databases that
they use we have a very high degree of
confidence that um that those users are
verifiable
um also another piece of this is that
when they fund their accounts that
account also has to be tied to the
person who is
um who has signed up for the account
um in those instances where the database
doesn't
because there are instances of that then
the person is prompted to put to
actually upload a picture of themselves
with their photo ID and again with
respect to gaming across the industry
whether it be sports betting or horse
racing or other eye gaming that is the
industry standard our experience with
this is that there is a very very low
rate of fraud online in fact these
databases are incredibly
um
incredibly effective at identifying who
is opening the account
and the data that is associated with the
account again both the the what we call
kyc or know your customer uh information
that comes from the databases along with
geographic information that comes and
banking information that comes we have a
very very high degree of confidence in
who is coming in to uh to uh to to open
an account and operate an account
um and so those would all be things that
would be would be fleshed out in the
plan of operation
um and certainly we have an
understanding of what the what the
highest level of Industry standards are
and we would hold operators to that
level
other questions from the committee
representative Rutherford yes thank you
madam chairs I apologize I made a note
of this and didn't ask you so some of
the guidelines that it you know it sets
out on page one
um starts on on line 22. the it it the
legislation uh defines at minimum that
the operator
um
shall essentially submit a plan of
operation
for operating their their
business
um and it and it defines six or seven
things that uh
that it requires legislative by
legislation and the last thing it says
other requirements established by the
commission enroll that seems pretty
open-ended to me so I mean what other
requirements could you conceivably
um
ask for that maybe we could tighten this
up
rather than give a blank check to assist
the commission so I I appreciate the
question I I certainly understand I
think if we knew specifically what we
were what other issues might arise
um that we would have enumerated them
um and so I certainly understand that
the legislature's hesitancy to provide
that open-ended or rulemaking authority
um
what I would say is that often what we
don't this is a this is online gaming is
still a relatively new industry
um and the things that we see at that
come up as risks or things that we want
operators to do
um does change uh you know over a three
to six month time period we may see an
exploit that happens in another state
and it may be something that we would
ask I'm certainly cyber security is
something that we have put into this
bill but in the past it's not something
that has been
um
forward-facing in the legislation or in
the rule making but obviously that is of
the utmost importance right now we've
learned that so I guess the the my very
long answer is I don't know what would
come up
um I do think uh I understand the
reticence of the legislature I do think
from my perspective that having the
ability in rule making to be a little
more Nimble to address items as they
come up as opposed to coming back to the
full legislature and obviously the
rulemaking does go through uh jailcar
um is necessary given the the state of
changes that happen in the industry and
the the tempo of those changes
um so I can't tell you right now what we
might be asking for
um but certainly if we if we did come up
with something we would want to address
it with jail car within a three to six
month period as opposed to the
legislature depending on the legislature
schedule
follow-up all right thank you and I get
that I mean especially in and I think
probably and I and I I understand and I
can appreciate the desire to be nimble
and especially in an industry that is so
Tech oriented I mean you look at what we
carry around in our pockets versus what
we carried around two years ago is a
huge difference but I I but I I hope you
can appreciate you know my concern in
that
um you know it's open-ended and you know
so I think we have some we see we see
each other's so what kind of language
could we put in there that would maybe
um
um satisfy maybe some of my concerns
where we're giving an agency a blank
check to take technology and who knows
what with it I mean is there something
that we could add there to approve by
legislature approved by Ways and Means
um not to exceed uh uh something like
that or is the or or is that the only
way that we could achieve what you're
you're looking for what it's written
right now in number letter H line eight
so I I think you know perhaps tying it
back to an already existing statutory
requirement say another uh other
requirements that would fulfill the
statutory requirements as written
um would make sure that we are not
wandering outside of your original
intent
um I do appreciate the question and
understand the concern
um it's just that I can't see the future
but I I do think that that would perhaps
um give you some
um
uh assurance that we are not going to go
outside of what you you intended as you
approve this
um and obviously there are also the
controls in place of going through gel
car and ensuring and OLS is very
um
uh very good about making sure that we
don't wander outside of the statutes uh
Four Corners
um so uh perhaps language to that effect
other questions
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you okay I do not have any more
pink cards on SB 190 is there anyone
else here who would like to speak
none we will close the public hearing on
now
okay we will now open up the peering on
Senate Bill 189 and the chair recognizes
the prime sponsor senator timley
thank you madam chair it's been as long
as I've been here
um I appreciate the opportunity to do
the spell but I do want to just take a
sight diversion to answer a question
that came up about rules and do
understand the rules I serve as the vice
chair of jalcar for freshman legislators
that may not understand what jail car is
the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules and so anytime a
commissioner an agency wants to submit a
rule or rule change there are three
forms that the rules can take they can
do an emergency one which means that we
have an immediate issue that is Public
Safety related so a lot of times with
these coming out of DHHS in the
department of safety and because it has
a direct impact on citizen safety we
have an interim rule which is here's a
set of temporary rules we want to run by
while we run through rule making process
and the last one is a final rule
proposal which is here's the rule we
adopted after having public hearings and
vetting it out so that comes before it's
a 10-member committee that's made up of
both senators and legisl and house house
members that have to approve those rules
so in the case so what we just heard
where we're granting a rule-making
authority to an agency just understand
that's not a blank check it still has to
come back to the legislature and get
approval from the legislature
just to make sure you know it goes so
we'll go back onto this bill sorry for
my little diversion there
um so this this bill was brought forward
at a constituent request
um the short version of this bill is as
members of ways and means you know that
we've always have a concern about credit
carry forward how much money are we
holding on on to the state where um a a
person can take a deduction and we hold
it and we've we've made legislative
changes to reduce that credit carry
forward that dra holds from we're down I
think to 500 percent this year than 250
percent in a future year and then it
finally goes to we can only hold a
maximum of 100 of credit carry forward
for a business liability what this bill
seeks to do is is address one of those
issues and it's it's relative to the
business interest expenses that a
business has currently a business can
has to take that deduction over four
years so they're allowed to take 30 in
the first year of that deduction and 30
percent than 30 in the third year and
then the end they can take the final 10
to get 100 deduction out of their
business profit Stacks what this bill
seeks to do is accelerate that and so we
don't have these carry forwards that are
going forward it says that 100 of what
they incur in the first year can be
taken in the first year so we don't have
this carry forward of 30 30 percent
10 in the next years forward that's the
short version of this bill
um it just allows them to take that
understand that there are times when our
especially on multi-state businesses
here in the state compete with other
states for the for the manufacture of a
product so I'm going to use things like
freudenberg Anheuser-Busch that have
plants outside the state of New
Hampshire and when a business has to
um
when a business has to compete for that
product to make it in New Hampshire so
again a can of beer at Anheuser-Busch
can be made just as equally over in Ohio
or down in New Jersey and so each each
plant basically bids or for lack of a
better phrase competes for who gets to
make that those you know 100 000 cases
of of beer or or makes the widget in the
manufacturing in the case of freudenberg
right they can just easily make it one
of their outside New Hampshire plants
and so New Hampshire is competing to do
that so one of the ways we can help them
is to clean up this language to make it
so that second and third year they're
more profitable and be able to take care
of that understanding that New Hampshire
still gets a hundred percent of its
revenue and none of this the only
difference is instead of taking it over
four years we take the hit in the first
year then we our rate our business
profits tax are raised in sec in year
two three and four because we're not
taking this deduction off the business
profits
um I I I'll happily take questions but
I'll be honest with you I am by no
stretch an expert in the IRS code 163j
but there are some people here who are
basically we're decoupling this from the
federal government that allows this 30
30 10 deduction and taking it all up
front that deduction all up front so
again I think the big thing for revenues
is ways and means we're talking about is
just understand that we still get all
the money we're supposed to get the only
difference is it's in the years that we
take it so
thank you Senator is this going your
bill lets us go back to what we were
just doing a few years ago is that
correct I believe it does we adopted
that we adopted the IRS code a while
back and then they changed the IRS code
and so we're still stuck with that
change and so we're looking to bring it
back to the way it was so businesses can
better compete this would let us
decouple from that yeah make you New
representative play thank you my only
question Senator Lang is do you do
um I I I believe in constituent service
and servicing our agencies so I tend to
get a lot of phone calls
representative almie thank you uh I am
really confused here because the
language that
you've got
is totally different from that 30 30 10
can you explain how you get 30 30 10 out
of the that formula
um
that
caps the business expense deduction to
the sum of business interest income 30
percent of the adjusted taxable income
and floor plan financing expense
thank you so again I I my understanding
is this is a credit carry forward issue
so again a business can
they have a hundred percent of the
deduction in the first year but they're
only allowed to claim 30. in the next
year they can claim the balance of the
30 in the next year because we only we
cap it at 30 percent so they can cap
each year they can keep applying for
that credit carry forward of the
interest charge
um against the business profits tax but
they have to take it over four years to
get the full hundred percent so thirty
percent thirty percent thirty percent
and then 10 in the last year this just
moves 100 all the way up to the front
that's all
foreign
I heard that
that the other parts of that formula
that I read are from our specific kinds
of businesses that maybe usually
wouldn't come into it I'm hoping someone
in in back is going to be able to help
us figure out sure so again I I I'll ask
you to ask that question uh I think
Simon's going to speak Mr Thompson is
probably a good one to ask that question
thank you
all right other questions over here yes
representative Southworth
I'm Sharon thank you for taking my
question I didn't find the word in here
is this in some ways enabling it or is
it forcing them I was looking for kind
of the breakdown if it was better for
their business to still do the old
system can they
I actually don't know the answer to that
question I know I know uh dra is here
and they maybe I'll answer it again
because it says allow businesses it
doesn't say they must
I would argue that's enabling language
it's not mandatory different needs thank
you
okay I'm gonna oh representative fellows
um yes I'm just wondering if you can um
tell me the year or the bill number so I
could find the bill that changed it I
honestly don't have that information
okay
other questions from the committee we
have other people presenting just so you
knows that may be able to get more
technical on this uh representative
almond did you have another question are
you okay okay great thank you Senator
thank you okay
we will now recognize David Juve from
I think it might be best for the
okay I got an allen okay yes uh thank
you deferred and we will send it to Mr
Allen
and I'm going to kill your last name so
I'll let you thank you from Global
business Alliance welcome to ways and
these handouts or information previously
submitted to the committee but we
thought it would be good to have it in
explain your support of this bill and
why and yes please thank you yeah hello
chair Sanborn Vice chair jinnegan and
members of the House Ways and Means
Committee my name is Alan passetsky and
I'm a tax consultant for the global
business Alliance or GBA and I'm
testifying today in support of sb189
GBA proudly represents nearly 200
American companies with a global
Heritage and Advocates on issues that
impact the U.S subsidiaries of
international companies which employ
over 50 000 people in the state
in New Hampshire employment and
international companies has increased by
22 percent over the past five years
while the state's overall private sector
employment has decreased by one percent
New Hampshire makes third in the nation
in terms of the concentration of jobs
created by foreign direct investment
with nine percent of the state's private
sector Workforce being employed by
International companies additionally out
of the state's entire International
based Workforce nearly half of the jobs
in the manufacturing sector and you'll
find more of this information in the
materials we submitted before and that
you have in front of you now
so GBA supports 189 because it drives
business growth and employment in the
state by decoupling from the interest
expense limitations imposed by the
federal Internal Revenue code section
163j
let me explain a little further the
federal and state income tax purposes
corporations determine their taxable
income simply by calculating the gross
income subtracting their allowable
deductions one of the typical allowable
deductions for corporations is interest
expense the results from loans or debt
taken out to finance their operations or
expansion
like ordinary business expenses interest
expense has always been deductible
but this deduction was severely limited
back in 2018 federally
because of the tax cuts and jobs act as
a trade-off for other items such as a
much lower Federal corporate rate
when New Hampshire
decided to follow and conform with the
federal code in 2020 they were two years
behind which was good here New Hampshire
employers faced an inadvertent automatic
tax increase because they now conformed
sadly this tax escalates the cost for
companies who want to expand their
operations and increase employment in
the state but thankfully SB 8189 New
Hampshire now has the opportunity to
join a growing number of states that
have realized this Conformity creates
bad policy for investment
in fact there are 18 states that
certainly currently right now do not
impose any such limitation on interest
expense including Connecticut which
decoupled a few years ago
SB 189 would Finance would encourage the
financing of new Investments which is
especially critical in this time of
interest rate escalation
so allowing for this full deductibility
by decoupling as SB 189 would do would
enable businesses to devote more
resources to Workforce Development
initiatives research and development and
expansion
for these reasons we urge the passage of
SB 189 to ensure New Hampshire remains a
competitive destination for
international companies to create high
quality jobs I thank you representative
Moffett for sponsoring the bill and
chair Sanborn for the committee's time
and consideration and I'd like to answer
any questions right now
thank you very much for your
presentation representative has a
question yes thank you madam chair thank
you for coming and explaining this and
just to break it down into to layman's
terms here so when I file my taxes
personally I can write a hundred percent
of my mortgage interest off but as a
business I can't write 100 of my
business interest off because we've
coupled now with 163. yeah we have to
spread it out which then ultimately as
I'm understanding it creates a liability
for the state because we've got this
this deduction that's hang we're
carrying carrying forward
correct thank you good question let me
try to clarify sure because I think
there's been some misunderstanding based
on what I heard earlier
so like you said personal level you can
deduct your mortgage interest in full
businesses have this interest expense
limitation now it's a formula and you
may not be able to deduct all of it
for the amount you cannot deduct it
carries forward into the following year
and now we run the calculation again and
see how much you can deduct if you can't
deduct all of that now it carry forward
to another year
so what this bill would do is it would
say we're going to decouple and
beginning in 2024 you can fully deduct
thank you so
I'm just thinking about it as a small
business owner who I have an LLC
versus
my brother who has who's Incorporated
this uh are there differentiations in
New Hampshire based on how you've
Incorporated so could I write as an LLC
my business right off 100 but his
business only would carry right off
thirty percent thirty percent thirty
percent good question the provision
section 163j that's the code provision
only applies to corporations with
receipts in excess of a certain amount
which I believe currently is 25 million
dollars it might be a little bit higher
if it was index for inflation but that's
the range so corporations that have less
than that number of receipts or operate
differently as you said in a different
form they're not a corporation they
might be an LLC they might be an
version of All Me yes uh that would be C
corpse C Corps correct
not escorts
on and
we have no no way decent way of
estimating how much money we're talking
about
might hit
the
fy24 fy25 budget
on and I guess it would depend a lot on
whether a bunch of businesses decided
okay we've been putting off making this
investment but now we're all going to
make it in the same year
and I'm wondering if there's any way
given the huge numbers of oddities that
we've found in on
that we've got in our tax code right now
around the business profits tax that we
could smooth this out
okay so to answer your question as you
said and as we heard in the Senate
hearing the dra determined this was an
indeterminate Revenue number because it
just depends on so many facts like you
said companies could decide to invest
more it also depends how much the income
they have because when you run that
calculation I mentioned you don't know
all of those variables for every company
so to your question about leveling and
it goes to your question as well
representative Roche Ford is remember we
said that some interest is disallowed
and it carries forward to the next year
and then you run the calc and it could
go forward so if we make this bill
effective 1 124 as proposed as you're
pointing out representative Almighty you
have this carry forward perhaps for a
company from prior years now this was
effective 2020 so you'd have four years
potentially of carry forwards and I see
your concern would be that not only
would you be deducting your interest
from 2024 but some of the interest that
came forward from the prior years and
turned about the revenue one way to fix
that concern if people have that concern
on this committee is to provide that
that carry forward amount
prior years instead of being deductible
entirely in 2024 would be deductible
over a certain number of years say four
years so in 2024 you would only deduct
your 2024 interest
and then you would take one quarter of
your carry forward
2025 you would take the second quarter
2026 the third 2027 the fourth and now
you would be done you'd leveled it and
now you'd be on a go forward only basis
we have actually drafted an amendment if
the committee desires that would be a
thank you representative janikian thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question so in the scenario I just said
if we leveled it over four years but but
in 2024 if a company made a new
investment that would be deductible the
whole thing immediately it's 2024
interest yes would be fully deductible
it just the things coming from prior
years you wouldn't get all in one shot
which creates this potential Revenue
issue that representative Alma mentioned
excellent are you local if we had a work
session on this uh to join us again I am
not but I can be here very quickly thank
you wonderful and I do have a copy of
the amendment I could circulate please
we tried to make it as simple as
possible by just adding it on to the
current provision to expedite the
process here so I'll pass that out on my
way out that would be helpful thank you
very much oh representative fellows has
a question thank you madam chair um can
you give me some kind of sense of the
federal restriction is does it only come
into play when like a large percentage
of their expenditures are are interest
interest payments it's actually a
complicated calculation but to simplify
it
you look at your total interest expense
from everything that's a number and then
you look at your total taxable income
with some adjustments
and you could take 30 of that taxable
income as your deduction so if your
adjusted income is a hundred
you can only deduct thirty dollars of
Interest
if you happen to have 40
10 of it would not be allowed
if you had 20 it would all be allowed
it's a percentage of your income
that you're limited to in taking a
deduction
follow-up
so you're talking about gross income or
it's taxable no it's taxable income with
special adjustments but we could just
we're trying to simplify it um although
yes representative Platt thank you for
taking the question I assume that's a
taxable not really taxable income it was
its income that would have been taxable
except you have to add all the interest
back in so that you can do the
calculation that is one of the
adjustments to add the interest back in
thank you very much
uh Mr Juve did you want to come up now
okay great thank you because the only
other pink cards I have just FYI are
from the dra and I'm sure they'll be
here to help us technically on things
uh Juve
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Dave Juve I'm a senior vice
president for public policy with the
business and industry Association we are
here in support of Senate Bill 189. I'm
I want to actually take more of a 30 000
foot view level of this issue and the
first thing I think it's important to
understand is because this deals with a
decoupling from the federal tax code why
States choose to couple in the first
place and the answer is for businesses
in general it's helpful if state tax
laws mirror federal tax laws they're
familiar with federal tax laws and it
makes state tax laws easier to
understand and follow
in 2020 if I remember back correctly
when we chose to update our coupling
with the federal tax code I believe
up until that point we were coupled with
I think the 2012 IRS tax code so we were
pretty out of date in terms of newer
federal tax regulations so the decision
was made to couple and as I said in
general that is something that's
beneficial for businesses
what happened in the specific instance
is with the tax reform acts the federal
tax reform acts in 2017.
the federal government gave some things
in the federal government took us away
some things one of the things they gave
was was lower overall Federal corporate
tax rates
one of the things that they took us away
I'm not sure that's proper grammar but
in order to make up for that lost
Revenue was reducing some deductions
that businesses previously were able to
take and this interest deduction was one
of those examples
because New Hampshire is now coupled
with that
and it makes sense on the federal level
because companies got to take advantage
of the newer lower tax rate at the
federal level and there was you know
something that wasn't as robust as it
was but it all balanced out or maybe
worked out to their benefit
what happened in terms of this specific
provision at the state level though is
we were caught up in that deduction but
there was no corresponding benefit to
companies at the state tax level so
Madam chair I think you were correct in
in uh your statement earlier what this
bill is essentially doing or the result
of this would be to give back to
companies at the state level something
that they already had previous to that
federal tax reform
um the other thing I I want that was
mentioned but I want to emphasize is
that companies here in New Hampshire
um do compete with other companies
around the country and they even compete
within their own companies for other
locations around the company and as the
previous testifier noted a number of
states have already moved to decouple on
this issue and many many other states
are considering doing so so we would
encourage the committee to look
positively on this bill I would be happy
to try and address any questions that
you might have
100 babies
yeah just a uh maybe you can help me out
here
um it was mentioned that there's a
divide between big companies above 25
million on
and smaller companies and uh could you
clarify
how that the big companies the bigger
companies versus the smaller companies
that are affected are not affected by
this change
the the first of all it was the previous
testifier that mentioned that not myself
and I will take him at his word I don't
I am assuming that that is incorrect I'm
sure it is
um the change is that those larger
companies are ones that have to comply
with that new change in the federal tax
code if you're if you have less revenue
or you're structured differently uh
according to the previous test fire and
I believe he is probably correct you
don't need to comply with those specific
Provisions there may be others that that
I was
so my understanding then is that
this change
is helpful to those companies that are
above that 25 million dollar assuming
all that's correct
um are the ones that are helped the
bigger companies and the smaller
companies are simply not not affected by
this yeah they are not hurt by it but
but I if we can assume that all that is
correct
um that's correct this would benefit
companies that are above that threshold
but I would add those are also the
companies that are providing a huge
amount of employment in the state and we
want to make sure that they receive that
help especially if it's just going back
to the way things were before and it's
something that other states are already
implementing
us what the other
States received that we didn't
you said that on
when
we
um
went into conf week went into Conformity
with what the tax jobs and uh tax cuts
and jobs act had done on that other
states got a benefit
on four
on that balance this provision whereas
we didn't no I I thought I must have
been unclear
all states
this would have impacted all states that
were coupled to the federal tax code
what I meant to say and was I guess
unclear because of this negative
ramification on at the state level a
number of states around the country I
believe the number was 18 that the
previous testifier said have already
decoupled from the federal tax code
going back to whatever their previous uh
law was I don't if it was a hundred
percent the way it was in New Hampshire
then it would have gone back to 100
percent I don't know what all the
individual state taxes were that they
went back to but my point is
they saw the ramifications of remaining
coupled on this one provision and and
implemented a decoupling for that
yeah
do you have followed yes
um yes a second question
if you remember it again related to that
one uh
isn't it so that on
if a large corporation
moved here or stayed here they would a
number of them at any rate would be
using subcontractors inside New
Hampshire
I
well see I don't I don't really have a
way of of answering that
I perhaps I don't know but there might
be some Fallout that would help someone
else
I
you don't know I'm not sure okay
representative Phyllis uh thank you this
is a just a follow-up to representative
Ames question do you have any idea about
how many companies fall into that above
25 million here in New Hampshire that's
a that's a a good question I don't know
the answer to it but I know there is
someone here from dra and in their
um reluctant well they're they're
prohibited from talking about individual
companies but they can talk about
companies in the Aggregate and they
might be able to help you with that I I
yes okay thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question among the states
this is a follow-up on representative
almie's question
you mentioned that there are about 18
states that decoupled from the federal
uh regulations
what kinds of uh ramifications if any
have there been either to
companies choosing to or not to do
business in those States and on the
revenues that those states are receiving
I I'm it's a great question I don't know
the answer to it I suspect some of those
changes are so recent that that we may
not know the answer but but I personally
can't answer that I don't know is there
anyone who does
and how do we get that information
I
I guess I would ask the dra if they
might be able to query uh their
counterparts in other states
thank you thank you I'm trying to throw
dra under the bus but
representative all me yeah just
isn't on
would you agree that it's
um that this state depends a great deal
more on our business profits tax than
any other state depends on their
business taxes
I would agree and have often made that
point to the committee but I would also
remind the committee what Senate Bill
189 is essentially doing is going back
to a point that was all that was the
case in New Hampshire relatively
recently so it's not in my mind it's
certainly making a change from where we
are now but the change takes us back to
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and uh we will now welcome up the folks
from dra Keen Wong and Frederick and
Frederick I'm not sure how to pronounce
your last name so come on up
help us understand this
it's uh Frederick cool broth I'm the
director of audit for Dra thank you so
much
yeah that's really good
good morning members of the committee my
name is Keane Ming Wong text policy
council with the dra and with me is
Frederick Cobra Jr director of audit
with the dra the department does not
have a position on this bill and we're
here to answer any questions that the
committee may have
on it
um
maybe just some brief
information uh the the previous speaker
did talk about the the IRC Conformity
are the the uh for taxable periods
beginning on or after January 2020 we
are in Conformity with the IRC of
December 3120
for taxable years for taxable appears
beginning on or after January 2020 uh
the New Hampshire BPT is in Conformity
with the IRC of December 31 2018. and
the last time that changed prior to that
was for taxable years beginning on or
after Jan 1 2018 uh when we were in
Conformity with the IRC of December 31
2016.
um
and then the
there were some questions on the um
the the 25 million threshold uh
essentially the 163 J limitation is
applicable uh to it's Exempted it's not
applicable to taxpayers who meet the
gross receipts test of the IRC 448 uh
small C
the gross receipts test isn't average
gross receipts for the previous three
years
that does not exceed 25 million and that
number is then adjusted with inflation
and right now it's 27 million
just to be clear that's gross receipts
overall globally
they could be operating in New Hampshire
for Less this would still impact them so
that may encourage them to invest more
here yeah yes the gross receipts is not
specifically for New Hampshire it's on
the on the on the taxpayer itself yeah
yes thank you
are you open to questions now or did you
have more to present
um yeah we're open for questions okay
thank you madam chair I wanted to follow
up on a question I asked the
Mr Juve
when you give us Revenue estimates for
coming years you're basing that uh in
part on the business taxes that will
come in
if we wind up with a year when there is
a significant shift or let me change
that will there be at least a year where
there would be a significant shift if
this system goes in where we're not
getting tax revenue over four years
in little pieces
but one year when all of a sudden we are
not getting Revenue
in a big chunk
in one year
thank you for the question
representative I believe I think that
question is really
um it's a bit challenging to answer as
uh provided by previous testimonies it
we cannot really predict how taxpayers
behave in terms of their Investments
whether they will make further
investments in the future and therefore
incurring additional uh interest on
indebtedness
um essentially this is what it is it's
uh the 163j limitation is a limitation
on the on the interest in debtedness and
as a two two speakers before us are
mentioned
um you would calculate the limitation on
a year-over-year basis so if the
following year the business
increase additional
um interest expense that would add on to
whatever that's carried on carried over
from the previous year based on current
law uh carried over from the previous
year to calculate what uh in a sense in
essence is below the 30 limitation
um
without uh with this new proposed
legislation that 163j limitation would
be removed and the the taxpayers would
be able to
claim the the full business interest
deduction in the year itself
um
so it's
I guess the answer to the question is
it's a short answer would be it's really
indeterminable
representative horse thank you madam
chair thank you for being here taking my
question so
you've looked at these numbers for no a
lot of years
is it likely that a business that's
incurring these types of interests in
one year gonna have it in a following
year in other words
the business doesn't end it's ongoing so
year after year there's going to be this
either it's going to be I'll take it in
one year or it's going to be spread out
over three four years
would you agree with that is that
correct or
I don't think you'll like the answer
um
we we're not able to track that
information that deduction is taken on
the the federal level
um so it's a it's a line on the federal
return that we don't track it on on our
system so there's no specific line item
on the New Hampshire return it says okay
business interest deduction okay then we
can track it
so it's we're not able to okay so we we
follow up please so we do get the
revenue in year one we just it's not
spread out is that correct
under under current law you would get
the deduction uh anything that's less
than 30 limitation you would get that
deduction in the year one and then
anything in excess of the 30 is carried
over the expense as a uh in excess of 30
is carried over to the next year and
that would be considered as a business
interest paid or accrued in that other
year and then add on to any other new
business interests
um expenses incurred in that year
it all adds up together to calculate
that
that 30 test again
okay very good thank you
other questions from the committee
representative almond
thank you on
Gene I can't remember if you were in
your current position in 20. I don't
think so no so you can't it somebody
really should have at the beginning
explained to us what the process is when
we
we decide to couple or decouple can you
do that
on when we decide to go to a new level
of the IRS uh
tax code
and that we want to use or not use the
changes they've made
from what I can tell from the history of
the records that I that I could see is
that the dra did multiple I guess
presentations or uh
provide information to to the
legislators I'm not sure if it's
specific to the house ways it means but
I'm sure it was how Solutions yeah um so
there were presentations in terms of
each item that is relevant to New
Hampshire uh with uh with regards to the
the changes with the tcja
what current New Hampshire BPD law says
and then if conforming with the tcga
what's the impact if not conforming to
the tcga what's that impact so that that
information was disseminated
um and it included in there was the
foreign
do you have some more questions or did
you want Enlighten us on well I'm having
trouble trying to figure out how to do
this but I believe that we did not there
were incredible number of changes in the
tax cuts and jobs act and uh would you
believe that we didn't get given all of
them to look at that dra did a first cut
and I can't remember whether dra whether
they showed us this one or not at the
time
um
yes there there were
um multiple amendments to the original
bill when the tcga came out
um I think the the house had some
amendments and then the federal on the
federal side the Senate has some
amendments before it was finally passed
um I don't I I'm going to suspect that
when um the dra made its presentation to
the house Ways and Means or to the
legislators it would have been after the
bill was signed into law by the
president
um yes yes and that would have already
included all um relevant New Hampshire
related
items which would include that business
yes
my colleague thinks that we did take a
look at it
we don't remember why
uh Mr Cool broth did you have anything
that you wanted to add
no I'm just here because this is this is
complicated and two heads are better
than one okay great Tina's doing an
excellent job excellent thank you for
being here representative fellows
thank you
can can you give me any sort of idea
about what sort of company would have
interest expenses that exceed 30 per 30
of their
taxable Revenue I mean
is it 60 of their taxes or six six
Thirty thirty percent of their taxable
income what sort of
company or what what sort of operation
essentially this would be um applicable
to businesses that
make that take out that uh that take out
loans
um
that uh sort of
take out loans to to India in their
business activity so I I think that
would Encompass all sorts of businesses
um and in terms of whether it is
it's below the 30 or above the 30
percent so that thirty percent is
calculated on the adjusted taxable
income
um and so it's determined whether how
well that business is doing
I I don't think we can really I I
personally cannot generalize which
yeah in general manufacturing does have
to have a lot of capital outlays in
order to buy manufacturing equipment and
the property and the so forth so they
tend to have more borrowing costs
if that will help you so there are
the only thing I can think of are like
too extreme so tell me if either of
these is not correct one of them would
be kind of like a startup company who
who's buying like a lot of equipment or
get you know setting something up but
hasn't really produced anything yet
would be you know need be paying
interest on what they're trying to buy
on the other end would be something like
what what we heard about like a retailer
that's failing and so they didn't even
have any taxable income because they're
you know in the hole so and and they
probably were borrowing monies and that
could exceed so I it seems like two both
of those be examples uh thank you for
your question representative so as to
answer this specific question then go
back to your prior one maybe I'll take
them in reverse order so as far as which
Industries uh we would have to defer to
what the prior speakers from Dave jubay
from uh be IA and um and Alan from uh
from the Global Alliance uh in terms of
their view of which specific Industries
are generally impacted we would defer to
that we don't have a particular opinion
on that as far as
the uh to your second question uh it's
it's generally taxpayers that uh incur
significant amounts of debt relative to
their taxable income so
companies over the 25 million now 27
million threshold
that don't have as much taxable income
because they might have significant
other expenses that are generally
deductible and lower their gross income
down to their taxable income
that would be consistent with some
manufacturers again we can't get into
specific taxpayers but generally
manufacturers tend to have significant
expenses
um other industries that are expense
heavy are going to see their taxable
income
significantly lowered and that would
that would pull them into this section
of the IRC that would pull them into
this limitation
and of course they have to have a big
appetite for debt they have to be
companies that are incurring significant
amounts of debt in order to operate so
those are the type of companies that are
impacted by this
it's probably it's generally probably
not startups because they're probably
under the 27 million dollar threshold
but it certainly if they are rapidly
growing they could find themselves
in excess of that threshold and then uh
to the extent they are incurring
significant debt which many of them do
then they would find themselves impacted
by this but it's it is probably
generally more mature organizations that
have had the opportunity to grow find
themselves in excess of the the
threshold but require significant debt
to operate and incur significant
expenses those are generally the types
of taxpayers impacted by this
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair
so I understand that the bill
essentially asks us to restore the
situation prior to the 2017 Federal
changes and the adoption of those
changes in New Hampshire in 2020.
am I correct that the mechanics here
are that the bottom line of the federal
return effectively is the top line of
the New Hampshire business profits
return
and so if we adopt this it'll be very
easy to monitor in the years ahead
exactly what adjustments are being taken
because effectively the New Hampshire
business taxpayer would enter in an
adjustment that would reclaim the
portion that they had excluded and
deferred on the federal return so we're
going to be able to see precisely
and monitor this over the next several
years what impact it may be having on
New Hampshire revenues
is that correct yes uh thank you for the
question that that would be correct uh
the that would be an additional line on
the BPT return just to record the the
Delta between what's allowed on the
federal and what's allowed on the New
yes um there is a business in
uh
the newspapers now
on which is very large
and incurred a lot of debt trying to a
mature business tried to incorp incurred
a lot of debt trying to work its way out
of its whole and is now in bankruptcy
what happens to our tax when there's a
bankruptcy
not identifying that business obviously
taxes on profits though uh yeah thank
you for your question representative
almi
um
that's
generally a complicated question we have
a team of lawyers here at dra and at doj
the Department of Justice that we deploy
to protect the state's interests in the
bankruptcy court system we have a team
of lawyers at dra specifically that
monitor all bankruptcy filings and
identify not just
um
existing uh debt of the state but also
potential debts um
um
tax distressed taxpayers that
potentially have a New Hampshire
obligation that has not been flagged for
the bankruptcy court so we do have a
robust system in place to identify those
potential debts that would be either
discharged or satisfied in bankruptcy
as to the specifics of any individual
taxpayer obviously I can't get into that
and it does vary
um
I know our annual report or I believe
our annual report discloses our
the amount of bankruptcy debt that our
lawyers are able to claw back
um
but I don't have that number offhand
and and again uh it is often the case uh
that if a if a taxpayer isn't bankruptcy
and they've been in significant distress
for some amount of time they may not
have much in the way of New Hampshire
debt because almost by definition
they've not been profitable for some
period of time sometimes it can come on
quickly though where they have had a
number of profitable years they do have
a potential liability owed to New
Hampshire they're now in significant
distress they've declared bankruptcy and
our lawyers will will make sure the
state's interest is protected and that
the the back taxes do get paid and and
representative stream uh thank you for
your testimony and thanks for taking my
question
um uh in terms of the tax cut and jobs
act
um uh you know as an offset I guess uh
for uh some of the lower tax rates there
were many
um uh limitations put on deductions uh
one of which you uh which is directly
addressed here is interest another one
uh I believe and I just asked for your
confirmation on this but uh we were
talking previously about mortgage
interest uh being something that's fully
deductible but in fact the tax cut and
job act reduced What's called the salt
deduction or state and local taxes and I
would just ask for for your view of
whether if your mortgage interest is
high relative to your tax to your uh
gross income
whether
at least federally whether your mortgage
interest would no longer be effectively
fully deductible
because of the salt limitations so and
that's something that's not addressed At
All by this bill
um I think I think my answer is that um
the this bill is relating to the
business interest deduction and not to
mortgage interest deduction
um
so
um and I
and I don't know the answer how mortgage
interest deduction is impacted
satisfactory yeah that is kind of really
separate from what we're entertaining
here um but we could certainly uh maybe
next year or later this fall welcome
back the CPA Society they've given us a
nice overview of taxes we could welcome
them back to do that representative orrs
thank you madam Karen thanks for taking
my question so you guys are obviously
excuse me a wealth of knowledge
in your opinion or in your estimation
with your experience I probably should
ask
is there any material difference in the
revenue stream from year to year do you
think whether we went back to 17 18 19
if this was changed in other words on a
12 billion dollar Revenue you know
budget or 14 billion dollar budget or
this year maybe a 15 billion dollar is
the the number we're looking at is it
material
uh once again that's a that's a question
that we might not be able to answer uh
because when looking back at the the
revenue stream as you can tell
um
during covet when you were expecting
that business taxes would drop
however businesses were doing really
well and our business revenues had
increased
it is there's so many elements that's in
play that goes into the the business
Revenue business tax revenue that we
collect uh so this
because of that change from um when we
were in conformity
with the the tcga is also right about
the time with
um
with covet
it's it's really not we're not really
able to track anything uh in that in
that area thank you
representative jinnegan thank you madam
chair
thank you for taking my question
wouldn't it be fair to say that while we
may be concerned what we're losing by
implementing this we don't know what
we're gaining by implementing this
because where there is competition among
states
who knows there could be companies
that'll say okay yeah New Hampshire is
now one of those States I want to invest
in
and so now we're potentially collecting
more business profits uh because now
that state that company has decided to
do operations in this state is that true
I believe that could could be a
potential um
outcome of the of the bill
but of course we don't have a crystal
ball
other questions for the dra
thank you and they gave us a great quick
guide hopefully you all have that
um and maybe did you send the tax
Foundation information as well yes the
the list with the states yes yes
excellent thank you I want to make sure
everyone saw that okay great I don't
have any other pink cards on Senate Bill
189 are there's anyone else oh rep uh I
apologize
okay
um we're gonna invite back let me see if
if you'd allow me five minutes two
minutes two minutes two minutes thank
you so many points that were made okay
thank you left unanswered perhaps and
try to clarify
um there was a question by
representative elberger a while ago
which asked about the other states that
decoupled and is there any study that
might show the revenue impact of that
and I can pretty safely say that data
doesn't exist it's just so nuanced as
dra said to actually tailor a revenue to
this specific provision in a specific
year that I but I will say that no state
that has decoupled has attempted to
recouple because of a perceived Revenue
loss from what they did beginning in
2018 or later to a question by
representative fellows on the types of
companies that might be subject to this
other than the 27 million dollar
threshold and again that threshold is
receipts so it's any dollar a company
gets anywhere it's not New Hampshire so
it's it's many companies subject to this
it's not industry specific I agree with
the comments made by several including
the chair that it's typically Capital
intensive manufacturing Industries
because they borrow the most but all
companies will borrow just like people
borrow to buy a house many few people
are paying cash companies invest their
their profits so they don't have cash
available so they borrow even if a
company decides they want to put some
office space in across the street to do
something they may have to invest in
that office space they'll take out a
loan to invest and they may not have the
taxable income number to deduct all the
interest on that loan I mean our
organization has 200 members of all
industries from Pharmaceuticals to food
and beverage companies to Consumer good
companies to r d companies and that
would be another one that would be very
subjective to this is company investing
in research and development so it really
is industry neutral for the most part
really is across the board that this
would apply
um and I think to uh representative
janigan um to your point and I think it
was a great Point as we're talking about
the revenue potential loss again this
does get us back just to what the
revenue would have been in 2019 it's not
creating a new law it's going back to
where we were and New Hampshire has
decoupled before recently with bonus
depreciation Section 179 so it's not new
ground but you're right if any
Investments come in as a result of this
and they should that will increase
revenues from those Investments which
will trickle down to not only the large
companies the larger making investment
but to the suppliers and the other
smaller businesses in the state that
will operate with the larger company so
it will trickle down as well so I hope
that clarifies some of the questions
raised
thank you so much
okay
all right any other pin cards for Senate
Bill 189
seeing none we will now close the public
okay and we will now open up the hearing
on Senate Bill 260 and the chair
recognizes the prime sponsor Senator Tim
Lang welcome back thank you I believe
this is my last bill
um in front of ways it means so
um this bill was brought to the
constituent requests
um they a constituent called me and
asked me to look into an issue that they
were having with dra and the issue was
this so and it's a yes if you understand
uh llc's and specifically professional
LLCs so dentist dental offices medical
practices
lawyers office CPAs you can't start one
of those practices unless you are
actually a dentist a lawyer a doctor or
a CPA I can open a CPA firm I need to be
a CPA in order to do that so what
happens in llc's is that you have
members uh the member owners as well as
you may have W-2 employees in the
instance of the constituent it gave me
it was a dental practice
and he had a situation where he had
three member owner dentists and
three-member owner W-2 employees who
worked for the dentist
and so if you're a W-2 employee you know
you get you get your your salary your
fix your fixed salary and then you may
get a bonus based on your
um effort how much effort and how much
money you made the company you'll get a
bonus based on that and doctor's terms
they talk about rvus or relative value
units for a given procedure no more rvus
you have the more your bonus structures
is increased
um and and that that follows across a
lot of Industries like lawyers and CPAs
the amount of effort you put in is is
consummate to the amount of bonus
compensation you may receive above and
beyond your salary
if you're a member owner those num those
names change even though they are
supposed to mean the same thing as your
member owner you may get a draw
instead of a salary and you may get a
disbursement instead of a bonus the idea
being in this in this particular
instance with the with the owner was
they were
dra had
um charged them the business profits tax
for the disbursement to the owners even
though the Compensation Plan was equal
to that of the W-2 employees so again so
say a W-2 employee makes a hundred
thousand dollars and has a hundred
thousand dollar bonus and then the owner
takes a hundred thousand dollar draw and
a hundred thousand dollar
um
disbursement they were treating 100
dollar disbursement as business profits
disbursement and charging them eight
point five percent on that when I
reached out to dra and I asked that
question does this happen
the interesting word I got back was
generally no
which wasn't didn't make me feel warm
and fuzzy with tra right it either
happens or it doesn't happen and if it's
happening and we're charging companies
we're charging what is considered comp
fair and reasonable compensation as
business profits because they're owners
that's an income tax and that's not what
was meant to happen
and so what this bill does is seeks to
clean that language up to make it clear
to dra that as long as the owner member
is taking a compensation that is
equivalent to the industry so again in
the case if I talked to the W-2 employee
against a hundred thousand dollar bonus
I mean a hundred thousand dollars salary
and a hundred thousand dollar bonus if
the owners are taking a similar a
similar type of compensation that's
that's commensurate with the industry
then that should be treated as income
and not profits disbursement
um
so uh so that's the is there were two
amendments done in the house so this
bill passed the Ways and Means Committee
with an amendment the amendment fixed a
typo somehow we we made the deduction to
the interest and dividends tax when it
meant to go to the business profits tax
so we had to add 77-a not just 77 uh so
that uh that uh editorial uh comment was
fixed and then the other thing we did on
the bill was just to make sure and it
was a dra comment that happened in the
in the bill in the hearing um there was
some concern about we could potentially
open up for a duplicate duplicate
deduction allowing someone to take their
full compensation deduction at the
federal level and take it again at the
state level so you'll see on the bill on
um lines four and five we talk about
that to the extent that the amounts are
not already deducted in here in arriving
at the business organizational gross
income profits tax so again what we want
to make sure is that I think it was
representative Pillsbury talked about
the bottom line of the federal number
becomes a Top Line of the state number
when it comes to business profits tax we
want to want to make make it absolutely
clear that they cannot deduct it again
and so it's kind of a belt and
suspenders action we don't think that
would happen but we also want to make
sure that it never does either so that's
the bill I'm happy to take any questions
and I'm not sure if anybody else has
signed up to speak someone else may have
questions thank you very much
representative homie
thank you
in 2009
I and representative hatch and the
entire Ways and Means Committee spent an
incredible amount of time working uh
reworking
77a43
which is the the fair and reasonable
compensation for actual natural purpose
Services of a natural person who is a
proprietor partner or uh member or
member
provided to the business organization
on
that is not a profit that is on
compensation for the work that you did
inside of the business
um
and for on behalf of the business
it had been uh monkeyed with shall we
say in Prior years for about eight years
or more
um
and we needed to make sure that was
never done again
it sounds like what you're asking for is
what
the same is what this is
this does apply also to LLCs that are
filing business profits tax return is a
proprietorship or partnership which I
think is what you're describing
and which was the entire reason for
doing this because the LLC tax
made us realize what was going on
in terms of fair and reasonable
compensation and you're coming in with
yet another paragraph at the very end of
of
that is adding in customary which is not
defined
uh too fair and reasonable compensation
and I thought you were trying to talk
about corporations being added in but
you're talking about
about LLCs which are being run
as a partnership
correct
so thank you for the question so again
this this bill was driven by again first
the constituent response and then dra's
response said generally it didn't happen
which means that it does happen on
occasion and the purpose of the bill is
to make it absolutely crystal clear that
we don't have an income tax in the state
of New Hampshire and we're not taxing
draws and disbursements that are
reasonable and customary to be
considered compensation we're not
representative self-worth
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I appreciate that you
came forward for a constituent I think
we all try to do that but I'm always a
little skeptical about a legislation
that's kind of tied to one or two
constituents it appears at the moment
that there's not a broad need or I just
think we would have more people here and
more people you know representatives
from the business community so um it you
really like you said before this really
was for one constituent and then you
thought there might be a couple more
so let me be clear so I started with one
constituent but once I broached the
subject I had lawyers contact me with
issues that said that this is a similar
thing they were running into that's why
I reprovise those firms CPA firm reached
out to me and said this is a similar
concern of them so while I started this
conversation because of a single
constituent request I will tell you that
more than one person a significant
number of people contact me indicating
that they they think this is a fair Bill
and that they were treated unfairly with
dra to make it clear and crystal clear
that dra that compensation shall not be
taxes profits thank you for clarifying
that I just having been here quite a
while I'm just surprised that you know
the business Community isn't here itself
but thank you sure
all right representative janigan and
then we'll go around the room
thank you madam chair thank you senator
um
my concern with this I understand what
it's trying to do my concern is I'm not
sure it's clear enough
as to who it's helping because
llc's Partnerships proprietorships
LLCs that don't have transferable shares
they already can take a compensation
deduction
and they also well there's two things
they can take a compensation deduction
and their distributions are not taxable
so this almost seems a little too
let me also say I ran it by a couple of
CPAs both of them were confused as to
what this
actually was targeting towards so this
bill may need to be is the intent here
to Target it towards s Corps C Corps
things that that or or llc's with
transferable shares where there would be
attacks are you familiar with that again
so so the idea was that
um in with members and owners there
there was apparently there were
instances where dra was treating
disbursements to members and owners as
as a disbursement of profit so therefore
subject to the business profits tax I
don't know how many instances that occur
I know again the the comment I got from
dra was the word generally which made me
nervous because it should be clear that
we do or don't tax disbursements as
um as profits or as it is it a
compensation and not subject to the
business profits tax so the purpose of
this law is to make it crystal clear
that a disbursement that's considered
reasonable and customary for the
industry in considered income and not
subject to business profits
disbursements and not subject to
sorry I think I started yeah
representative Lloyd you were here yeah
um this may be have may have already
been answered but um are we certain I
know you were working with individuals
are we certain that this wasn't a
payroll processing error in some way
shape or form rather than uh an overall
arcing issue
so again I can only I'm going by my
response from dra not from the
individuals again the response from dras
that there are occasions apparently
there were occasions when disbursements
were considered business profits that
maybe shouldn't have when they use the
word generally right because it should
be an absolute no we don't if it's
reasonable and customary compensation we
would never charge business profits tax
to that which should have been the
answer I was expecting if it wasn't the
I just realized I pay all these taxes so
both of these bills might impact me I
don't even know but I should probably
mention that representative Platt thank
you for taking my question what is
reasonable compensation sure so again
dra can use any number of sources to
look that up uh I I use it when I had my
business and I was looking for
compensation for the difference between
a network engineer and a network
technician what was reasonable
compensation so there are plenty of
Industries that'll use the I forgot the
name there's a business code for almost
every job and you can look up what
reasonable and fair compensation in the
industry and for your region is using
Labor Statistics as well
so Department of Labor puts statistics
out for those same exact things that'll
tell you what the the basic compensation
for any given profession is
representative Elber
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I'm looking at the
notes that were distributed by the dra
and the last paragraph
mentions that the language in the bill
does not appear appear to be consistent
with the stated intent
and the dra would note that there may be
risks to businesses if they treat
payments as in quotes compensation for
New Hampshire purposes in order to get
the BPT deduction but treat the payments
as distribution of earnings for federal
purposes can you please comment on that
so I don't have your I don't have the
notes that they distributed so but I can
if the language needs to be clear I
think I've been absolutely crystal clear
on what I'm trying to accomplish here
and what the bill in the Senate and the
we did make again to meet dra's requests
that idea of the duplicate deduction to
make sure it was crystal clear that
couldn't happen and that was a comment
um and there was another question about
constitutionality where we made a minor
change that cleaned it up to make it
what so it was constitutional I think it
had to do with the uh the interest of
dividends tax reference is why we
cleaned that up it was a mistake it
wasn't intended so
um again I I think the intent and the
language on his face is crystal clear
that income given to members and owners
that is considered reasonable fare and
customary should not be taxed the
business profits tax rate and that
representative Orris thank you madam
chair thank you sir so if I understand
this right so if they were charged eight
and a half percent the owner and they
withdrew a hundred thousand today
and they're claiming that as income are
they paying taxes as income also as in
like in a W-2 if I was getting a W-2
when I worked at BAE Systems
BAE Systems is covering a lot of those
taxes but as an individual employer
I'm usually paying a lot more tax
usually about 45 cents on the dollar so
were they paying both in this case
so thank you for the question so I guess
the short answer is yes right again so I
owned a bit I had a computer consultancy
business with 22 employees that I met
and I owned and managed and when I took
my draw
and my disbursement I did it within the
within the confines of what is a network
engineer makes that's what I was really
I was an owner in business but I really
just a network engineer with some
additional duties and so for me yes I I
paid when I was left I took that
deduction out I didn't get caught in
this issue that's going on but I would
pay for my draw and my disbursement I
would pay federal federal income tax on
those wages but in the case of at least
a couple instances we know that these
other people are paying not only their
Federal wages because it's income when
we don't have an income tax they're also
paying the business profits tax on that
disbursement
both
thank you so
if you pay you paid your federal income
tax did you also have to pay both sides
of your Social Security tax on that
as a business owner I'm an answer yes
yeah because
as an employee of BAE Systems Bae paid
half of my Social Security you which is
about 15 whatever percent and so as a
business owner you paid about 30 percent
maybe 31 I forget what the exact number
is okay so you paid your federal tax you
paid your 31 Social Security and blah
blah blah tax and you also ended up
paying eight and a half percent on
business profits tax so they double
dipped you
so again I I think that's an accurate
statement again as a business owner you
end up paying both sides of it and
that's just the nature of it even though
it is a there's a veil that's between
your personal income and your
professional income right
um but ultimately yes in that instance
they would pay both okay so as somebody
that's worked in the business all their
lives I've owned my own business twice
and I've also worked for big
corporations it sounds to me like they
double dipped you so this this to me
sounds very clear that we're
this this looks like we ought to pass
this in my opinion but that's just based
on what I heard today so so again thank
you thank you you know my again my
opinion is again
I wasn't comfortable with the word
generally
that Led Led to us some ambiguity and I
wanted to make it crystal clear that
income for owners and members shall not
be taxed to business profit sex yes and
ambiguity is really difficult to deal
with as an accountant or anybody that
deals with numbers thinking as expecting
dra to say A dollar is a dollar not a
sort of a dollar so
keep in mind this is a public hearing
and we are asking clarifying questions
of the bill sponsor saw some hands over
here anyone have question representative
uh
fair and reasonable compensation
means in at this point it means
compensation for professional work or
manual work cleaning the toilets
whatever you did in your business
on
it does not mean anything you decide to
now what you're doing is saying any um
the people that set all of this up back
in the days when only Republicans were
writing the law on
did not want us to allow the lawyers and
the doctors and others dentists to
to take all of their the revenue of
their business as a business expense
that could be deducted so that they were
paying no taxes whatsoever
Benson actually created by when he was
head of of his his company on
suing the state because only the big
businesses were having to pay the
business profits tax that have been put
in
are we at a point where we can just
decide that all Professionals in and
owners of llc's are going to be able to
avoid paying taxes
and if we are are we going to go back to
another lawsuit from some big company
taking up what Benson Benson did because
they fixed the law that way the lawsuit
so thank you for the question again I
can only answer that fair and reasonable
compensation never be should never be
taxed at the business profits tax rate
in any situation so if if again using
whether it's the labor codes that they
use for given Industries and for given
uh job functions whether you're using
that as a measure of fair and reasonable
compensation anything that's above and
beyond that maybe fair game for subject
to business profits tax but anything
below that that's reasonable and
justifiable as as reasonable
compensation through a draw and and
disbursement should not be taxed at the
business profits tax rate
okay
follow-up can you believe that Mike
sorry uh you believe that Romans 3 does
not adequately cover that
I guess my answer is if Roman 3 adequate
covered I wouldn't got the word
Ames
yeah just following up following up on
that discussion
um I think what I'm hearing is that
um
that the issue you're trying to address
is
um
a
arguable ambiguity in the just a
reasonable compensation
provision that's already in the tax code
and your perception based on
and admittedly uh limited inquiry on
your part
is that some distributions
to owners
have been
rejected as reasonable compensation so
they then become taxable as a profit and
if if that's what we're dealing with
here I think you know for me I need to
hear more from gra about the scope of
the just and reasonable compensation
Clause it seems to me it's a very
appropriate division
to
um
effectively exempt from the private tax
the reasonable fair and reasonable
compensation received by owners
which may indeed
take place at the end of the year as a
bonus that's related to Services
performed by the owner
and if uh if that is and then that's
that's an appropriate dividing line
between
compensation
which is deductible and not subject to
an income tax here in New Hampshire
and on the other side the business
profits that are taxable and um
so
it's to me uh intellectually it's an
appropriate division of Concepts and a
place to have the tax and not have the
tax and we need to look closely at what
is actually happening make sure that
there isn't some
some movement in the wrong direction
I'm really afraid that this proposal
opens up a whole new
category
that creeps into the profit side of the
business and that's what we don't want
to do I think so I don't know you might
comment on that uh what I just said
so again I I think we're we're
conceptually on the same path right we
agree that fair reasonable compensation
should not be taxed at a business
profits tax rate
but the determination of what is and
apparently that is in question at dra
and so therefore I felt this bill
brought being brought forward made it
crystal clear that um and it and Beyond
and to the other thing I also look at
this bill as giving some protections to
a taxpayer right so it gives if an owner
is charged at eight and a half percent
they can point to this law point to the
Labor Statistics or whatever
model they use you know dun and
Bradstreet whatever they want to use for
showing what a reasonable and fair
compensation package is and why they
shouldn't this law gives that taxpayer
the consumer protections to do that
their taxpayer protections to do that by
saying under this chapter I'm entitled
to fair and reasonable compensation
um and here's how I justify that
compensation and gives them a leg to go
to dra and at least challenge the ruling
okay
let's just try to make sure we're asking
questions and not trying to debate this
topic with the sponsor representative
orrs thank you madam chair
so I I enjoyed rep armies and rep Ames
narrative and I think the confusion is
and the camp the compensation part what
what you're actually drawing out of the
business so let me ask the question in
terms of how would you
get paid or how would you enjoy the
fruits of your labor in your business if
so I'm not quite sure
how to answer that question because I'm
not sure I understand it but I will tell
you let me let me rephrase that question
so you're working along and let's say
you you're going to draw your
compensation once a year based on how
well your business does so maybe one
year you decide that
I've paid my employees fifty thousand
dollars
whether the business was doing well or
not well why don't we stay a hundred
thousand dollars we'll just stay with a
hundred thousand dollars but you see the
businesses not doing so well so maybe
you draw less than a hundred thousand
because you need to keep cash and
whatever in the business
so if you drew only fifty thousand
dollars at the end of one year the
second year the business is doing great
the employees still got paid to say
maybe they got a wage increase but they
still got paid about a hundred thousand
now your your business is doing very
well you only Drew fifty thousand last
year so if you Drew Drew 125
the second year at the end of the second
year that would to me seem reasonable
compensation
if you didn't draw the 125 000 how else
would you have put a money in your
pocket to pay your bills so does that
help yeah it does but you probably like
fancy because I don't I don't think it's
reasonable right again as a business
owner I've done that right so I own my
business for 12 years and they were they
were in 2008 was a really rough year to
own a business
um and so in 2008 I lowered my
compensations I could make sure I could
take care of my employees that I had to
make sure that I had money to pay their
you know I paid 100 of the insurance I
paid you know a lot of things that
tracked employees and to keep employees
and so
um I I I took that however in the second
year if I was to say well I'm going to
make up the what I lost last year I
would honestly classify that as a bonus
a bonus uh disbursement and I I mean I'm
not a bonuses person but a disbursement
of profits and I'd be subject to
business profits tax yeah that's my
that's my belief that's the way I would
treat it and that's the way I did treat
it when I owned my business well uh
follow follow up so I'm I'm surprised to
actually hear that so I mean in my mind
it's like I'm trying to equalize my
salary over a number of years and just
not one year but okay so if it was the
second year was only a hundred thousand
again you need to draw money at some
point to pay your your personal bills
Etc right so that's basically your
income is that correct correct thank you
okay we're just going to go around the
room this way again representative
elberger thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question I'm looking at um
the text in here under uh XX
it talks about
uh compensation for members and owners
now I know who employees are I know who
owners are
I don't know who members are and I'm
curious as to number one what are they
and number two what might they be
contributing to uh lead to them getting
some kind of compensation thank you so
that's the difference between the forms
of of Corporations the way you set up
your NLC has members
so
okay so follow up
which is the equivalent of an owner just
uh so just a funny as they use in an LLC
the members
are in effect the owners thank you
okay going around the room
representative Stringham sorry uh uh
thank you for taking my question uh just
follow up on the other thing is is there
any reason a member of an LLC can't get
a 1099 or a W-2 for whatever their their
uh fair and reasonable uh distribution
or compensation is for the company and
wouldn't that be deductible thank you
I'll be honest I don't know the answer
that question I wouldn't want to
speculate
okay
okay great thank you so much
uh the only other pink cards I have are
from the dra I don't have anyone else on
the is there anyone else here who wants
to speak on the bill okay uh keen and uh
Fred do you want to come up and
good morning Fred cool broth again
director of audit New Hampshire dra
Kim text policy Council of dra and it's
probably appropriate
um first for me to start off by
apologizing to Senator Lang because
um in uh
over at dra were a bunch of tax lawyers
and accountants and tax experts and we
have the admitted failing of overly
relying on the word generally absolutely
the world of tax policy is super
complicated I know it comes across that
way to you all and believe me it comes
across that way to us as well and so we
have almost a reflexive deferential use
of the word generally when maybe it's
not always appropriate so
um
it's probably helpful to start this
conversation with uh
yes to answer Senator Lang it is it is
crystal clear that if
um
compensation is paid by a business
organization
to an owner of any kind of entity
that is
reasonable
to it to a natural person you can't pay
you know if you can't re-characterize an
expense that you're paying to a company
as compensation
and under this section and consistent
with Section 162 of the federal
Internal Revenue code
yes it is crystal clear that is 100
deductible
it's also probably noteworthy to point
out that um
the
the history surrounding this deduction
and what was permissible and what was
not permissible in recent years really
focused on
the determination as to what is
reasonable compensation what is not and
that led to the
um the audits that generated some
notoriety over at the legislature uh 10
or 15 years ago and which resulted in
the
the burden shifting to the department
now so under existing law as as the
deduction is currently drafted uh me and
my team have the bear the burden of
proving that compensation is
unreasonable
um I'm not going to get up here and tell
you all that I think we're getting that
right now because that would seem really
self-serving but I think the fact that
you know for the most part folks are not
coming up to testify as to whether or
not the dra and the audit division is
overly aggressive on the determination
are reasonable I think that
can hopefully speak for itself that
um the the way that this the deduction
currently works
taxpayers are General there see there I
go again taxpayers are able to deduct
compensation when it's reasonable and
again I don't want to say I don't want
to come up here and appear self-serving
but that's not what's generated the
dispute today and I I don't want to
certainly don't want to speak for
Senator Lang but I've not heard that
today
um the issues that do come up under
audit are these types of situations
where a company is
re-characterizing a payment to another
company as compensation but it's not or
um or as would be the case when they've
made a profit distribution that's not
paid not paid for services
but they want to deduct it as
compensation if it's not if it's not a
distribution
in exchange for services provided by
that employee that owner employee to the
company then it's not deductible
but certainly uh the owner of a company
who pays herself pays himself
uh let's say a sort of Baseline salary
and then pays themselves a quarterly or
end of year bonus
those are for South if that's if that if
that bonus
is
for services
it's going to be deductible
uh
again it's it's not in those limited
situations where they're trying to
re-characterize something else as comp
but but it's not
um and the I forget who who was asking
about the note that we said that we made
in our
uh in our deliverable to you all noting
that there could be some potential
Federal consequences yeah you you
certainly don't in your IRS audit you
certainly don't want it to come out in
front of the IRS auditor that you're
characterizing things for New Hampshire
one way in the in the feds another way
the IRS Auditors are not going to look
kindly on that that's sort of a tangent
but just
um and then to
um
in further comment to
um uh representative Orr's on um
uh this notion of if you're if your
company
underperforms in one year so you have to
give yourself a salary cut in one year
because you just don't have cash you
don't have cash on hand at the end of
the year or whenever you're making your
bonus distribution uh and so you you
take a pay cut
that is absolutely deduct you pay
yourself that in the next year so-called
catch-up comp that is deductible in the
next year that Crystal Clear
um again that the way that comes in to
the deduction
is through the reference in the existing
deduction to section 162 of the federal
code and the case law that exists under
that deduction and if you look at the
deduct if you look at the the case law
surrounding that deduction and as it
exists in the first circuit which is
what would be the circle applicable to
New Hampshire
that is allowable and so we would we
would respect that and we would have to
because that is the law
um so I just wanted to clarify that
um there's some sort of
wonky issue as to if it's sort of
reasonable either way it doesn't really
matter because if it's still reasonable
you don't even have to make the catch-up
comp argument but certainly if there
were uh you know some concern then it
doesn't matter because it's still
ketchup comp and yeah you're allowed to
make yourself whole again in bad years
that's that is the state of the law so
again to the extent this has sort of
spun off of
our reflexive
overuse of the word generally I totally
understand where Senator Lang is coming
from on that again this stuff is so
complicated that even sometimes the
folks like us who who are dealing with
it all the time even sometimes we get
Squishy on it and that's that's not
exactly a service to anybody uh so I
apologize
um but again
within the existing deduction if if
an employee owner of any entity is paid
compensation for services that are
reasonable under Section 162 with the
benefit on their side on on their side
It's deductible
representative Platt
thank you for taking my question are you
saying then that uh this bill is not
necessary
thank you for the question
representative
um
right right
if if that's all it's seeking to do in
in my view and I I honest in in the
Department's view
um it's duplicative it's it's redundant
um
if it's seeking to do something else I I
don't know what that would be I'm happy
to work with with Senator Lang or any of
you to if if there is a perceived
uh Gap
we're happy to to work with folks and to
close that Gap you know to help you
draft language that would close that
um we're happy to work with whoever
wants to follow up does the bill do any
harm
so
to the extent it creates confusion
um
potentially so if
the the
if tax if taxpayers only use it
essentially as a second you know they
get to choose between
deducting under Roman 3 or this other
line on the return
no it doesn't do any harm it's it's
redundant uh
it there's no potential Revenue impact
um it's it's just an alternative means
to deduct what they could already deduct
if it somehow signals to folks that
something else is permitted that wasn't
previously permitted
then it could potentially do harm I
don't know how we quantify that I don't
know how we determine what that would be
that would be my main concern is
what what folks would view that line or
what that what folks would view that
me we'll go back around the room
thank you so if we passed this and we
had Romans 3 which everyone's used to
and we uh now had Roman 15.
you would have to write rules that
explain
what customary means and how this is
different from fair and reasonable
thank you for that question
representative all me uh
yes I believe I believe that's correct
um
have you got any idea what that would
imply
so
not not as of yet that
that's a complicated question
um
there's there's probably significant
overlap
with that term and what already exists
under the existing
federal case law that interprets 162 and
that we're required to use
so
it may not be all that different or any
different as a practical matter but I
think
by introducing the term I think dra
would likely need to Draft rules to
further clarify that whatever Federal
definition it has in the case law that
that's what we would be using because
thank you and if it what I'm hearing is
that any disbursement to a member owner
is
reason is customary
or fair fair reasonable and customary
on if
that on
interpretation held
wouldn't all Partnerships and
so
again that that that's a complicated
question
um
and this it
I think
relates back to the point you made about
um
uh the history of the business profits
tax and why we have the business
Enterprise tax because the business
Enterprise tax does exist as a
counterbalance
frankly for this deduction
um
I mean it is
often the case that
smaller companies regardless of how
they're structured regardless of whether
it's an LLC or corporation that has
elected S Corp status federally or
whatever
it is often the case
that they don't have taxable business
profits because
they have to employ whether they're
owners or just regular employees they
have to employ
very expensive labor they have to hire
lawyers
dentists
doctors whatever the practice is
whatever the firm or businesses if they
have expensive employees who ultimately
become owners
they have to pay those people at market
and that might mean there's not a whole
lot if any in the term of in terms of
taxable business profits
but there there are certainly there are
certainly smaller companies that pay BPT
for sure
just want to make sure we're keeping an
eye on the time here it's almost noon uh
yes for people yeah I also wanted to
just add to that we do have in statue in
Roman Tree
um part G
that the business organizations that's
claiming this deduction that their only
burden of proof of other than meeting
the 162a one of the federal code is to
show that the Proprietors partners and
or members that are claiming uh that
they did actual provide personal
services
to to the business and then once that
organization has satisfied that burden
approved the amount claim as a deduction
shall be presumed to be reasonable so we
do have that coded in in the Statue
currently
um
and if if the business was able to say
that oh yes the uh this particular uh
member or owner had
provided
um a million dollars worth of service
um that would be presumed reasonable
representative Southworth thank you
thank you for taking my question now if
um
something is disallowed I assume the
taxpayer has plenty of time to talk to
you and get detailed information about
you know why is this allowed and so on
so we really don't need to change
legislation for a taxpayer to do that
and kind of defend their choice and all
of that you I assume you have a
procedure there there is absolutely a
procedure so any whether it's
disallowing a deduction we're issuing a
notice of assessment any any action the
department takes is appealable
um uh and I want to be respectful of the
time so I'll keep this briefer than I've
been but yes there is a process in place
they have appeal rights
thank you for your question
do you think there's any possibility
that the form could be confusing to
people because if for example
um
the example that one of the things it
says in in the statute is that the
compensation for the the owner can't be
so high that it causes the business
profits
profit to go from above zero to below
zero so they give themselves a lower
compensation that year but they're
trying to make up for it the next year
is there a confusion when you get to
this the second year that they don't
know that they should probably I assume
they're supposed to report it as
compensation and if it looks really high
there's some kind of explanation or no
do you think they get confused and they
call it a distribution
I've not seen that I'm certainly
open though to that conversation and we
can
we would be willing to further clarify
uh the forms if that's if that's causing
people confusion I've not heard that but
we'd be open to working with folks to
clarify that thank you for your question
okay yes representative Orr thank you
madam chair and thank you gentlemen for
taking my question so if my esteemed
colleagues here knew what a wealth of
information you two are
uh and how spot-on your answers are
I think we would get through this sooner
I just have the advantage of
I wish you guys have worked for me back
in the day so my question is
generally speaking
I just want to add to that as well
um
that in when the committee is
considering to uh to pass or to uh
however the committee decides on this
bill is that the current legislation
Roman tree has built in all this
language as representative aubi
mentioned in terms of guard rails of
um how uh what is determined as fair and
reasonable compensation and how it's
deducted and and so on and so forth
um having this additional new um
section
um if it is if the intent of that
section is to accomplish the same
thing
but this new section lacks the the guard
rails that is available in the current
statute language
um it as what Fred mentioned it could
cause some confusion with the with
taxpayers or with practitioners in terms
of what exactly is the intent of this
representative Ames
can't resist this goes back to my
earlier question what what was just
brought out
um isn't it true that any time a statute
is added to with a new provision that is
similar to but not word by word the same
as
the other provision
that for the agency
implementing that statute there
is an expectation and for any Court
reviewing actions under the that statute
there will be an expectation that this
new language
has added something
and that there will be some burden on
you to explain what that added is and
the arguments and confusion are
generated if the if the original thought
yes representative Ames thank you for
your question and that and that is an
excellent point
um that that that is absolutely a tenant
of statutory construction it's called
the Pres it's a presumption so
um yes if the the addition of this
deduction
even if it is
totally duplicative at the end of the
day as a practical matter does create a
presumption that it does something
different
um
and then so whichever party wants to
make the argument
um that it does not has the would
potentially
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for your clarifying answers I
have no other pink cards for Senate Bill
260 is there anywhere anyone else here
who wishes to speak seeing none we will
close the public hearing on House Bill
excuse me Senate Bill 260. we will take
a lunch break we are scheduled for an
exec session at 1 30. so I will see you
then
good afternoon
looks like we have some substitutes here
with us so if you wouldn't mind just
saying hello and introducing yourself
welcome to Ways and Means
hi representative Mary hacken Phillips
thanks for having me it's been a couple
years but I'm looking forward to the
discussion awesome thank you so much for
coming and anyone else over here well
representative Lloyd you've been with us
for a couple days but say hi hi
representative Lloyd from Nashua
yeah and representative Stringham thank
you yeah hi Jerry Stringham from Lincoln
Woodstock New Hampshire uh happy to be
back with Ways and Means even for an
afternoon and representative nonner
I'm Janine nodder from Merrimack filling
in for Dan Hines again
thank you so much for joining us today
we will start uh with Senate Bill 17 and
we will now open up the executive
session on that this is establishing a
gifts and donations account within the
fish and game fund
and uh representative plett would you
like to make a motion I move ought to
pass is there a second
representative elberger seconds that uh
would you like to speak to your motion
in a second
yeah it's always challenging but the
clerk
this bill establishes a dedicated fund
it gets some donations within the
fishing game it's what it amounts to
yeah and so it's a non-game species they
don't have to get the approval of the
Fish and Game Commission or the
is there any more discussion on this
thank you I think it's just governor and
Council what's the problem
and it's the endangered and something
species
non-non-game species management fund is
that with it because there are a number
okay any other discussion
seeing none when the clerk is available
he will take the role on the ought to
pass motion on Senate Bill 17. okay I
shall do so Madam chair uh
representative uluri yes representative
Doucet yes representative spilsbury yes
representative yes representative
naughter yes representative sorry yes
representative orrs yes representative
yes representative army yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative Phillips heck and
Phillips thank you yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Lloyd yes
representative Stringham yes and the
chair
yes the vote is 20 to zero
being 20 to zero is there any uh problem
with it going on consent calendar
okay then it will be on the consent
calendar
thank you very much we will now close
oh
okay
okay we'll now open the executive
session on Senate Bill 51 which is
creating a commission to study
charitable gaming and historical horse
races and relative to the moratorium
unlicensed historical
horse racing facilities Madam chair yes
I'd like to move an amendment uh first I
need an ought to I haven't recognized
anyone for an ought to pass motion so I
first need to do that and then it would
be open to amendments okay and for the
record I am involved in this charitable
gaming industry and I will participate I
the chair recognizes representative
janikian for motion
thank you madam chair I move out to pass
on SB 51 okay and is there a second
representative Doucet seconds that would
you like to speak to your motion yes
thank you
um
our state has built a special charitable
gaming model over the years and this
bill continues that effort to continue
studying it to make sure that we are
moving uh moving along in in the correct
way it'll also examine how Charities are
selected a number of locations
and then there's also 250 000 allocated
to help effectively accomplish this task
and bring in uh experts as potentially
needed
um
so
it also and it also ends the um the
previous
um
permission
all right
we that the bill is now open for
Amendment so now I think it would be a
good time for you to move an amendment
and we can decide we can vote on that
oop I'd like to move Amendment one five
uh is so you you move that is there a
second
okay uh seconded by representative Army
um would you like to speak to your
emotionally
um yes ma'am cheer
um after the our session yesterday I was
looking at this uh Bill some more and
one of the things I recognized is that
for appointing it has a pointing
um
uh
members
representing the Charities and
representing the um
locations
and that in both cases it didn't
identify who would make that an
appointment so standard format for a
study committee or Commission
you know usually it starts out the the
president of the Senate re points Senate
Senators and that speaker the house
appoints representatives from the house
and for the other positions it
identifies who makes those appointments
so to address that situation which if we
passed it without this amendment I think
it would seriously hold up the formation
of the committee because there'd have to
be some kind of
you know resolution of who would make
those appointments so
um the amendment changes it to one
member appointed by the New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators
and uh they're the current bill has two
members from Charities but I changed
this to one member appointed by the um
New Hampshire Center for Center for
non-profits
so that's a technical correction
and
um I know Senator former former
representative abrami said that he felt
that the
a commission could go beyond the scope
of the items that were specifically
identified in the bill but I think since
I was making this one change anyway I
just added something to the bottom about
if other issues came up they could also
other comments on the amendment number
1517 representative Platt a question how
the New Hampshire Center for nonprofits
relates with all the non-profits in New
Hampshire they do a good job
representative set and then
representative oh whatever go ahead
I don't know I'm sorry and and to to uh
representative Platt's point Thank you
madam chair I didn't even know and I I
considered myself pretty well tuned into
the non-profits and the charities in the
state I don't know who these people are
so I I have no idea how to vote on this
amendment other than
without knowledge of
you know and I I was on that
subcommittee so I've never heard seen or
took taken testimony from this group
short of this piece of paper that was
handed out to us yesterday
representative
thank you I do know something about the
non-profits because I I
communicate with a large number of
different kinds of non-profits I presume
representative Lloyd knows something
about them too on but they do training
courses
both in financial matters and in
um in other legal matters for
non-profits
um
they seem to be fairly well respected by
the non-profit Community they haven't
specifically dealt with problem gaming
but they would be in a much better
position than the house clerk who I
think this would have to default to
to
um bring to the table
a variety of non-profits that are taking
money from charitable gaming
um
I'd like to
to ask representative Lloyd to say more
and also because she's in this field but
yeah when we were taking a testimony
um yesterday I I had asked who would be
doing the appointing of the non-profit
organizations because if you're looking
at a dollar amount in front of you for a
large non-profit that like if you're
looking at let's say two thousand
dollars that two thousand dollars may
just be a drop in the bucket but for a
very small non-profit that has maybe
five ten individuals who are working at
that company or that organization that
two thousand dollars could very well be
a huge amount in their budget so
um it just we want to make sure that
there's representation that's kind of
equal and and somehow decided in the
non-profits so
representative Malloy
thank you they testified and they passed
out this she to all of us the New
Hampshire Center for non-profits and
then on top of that they spelled out
their uh reason for existence and their
mission it's the strings and strengthens
and gives voice to the state's nonprofit
sector through leadership collaboration
and learning opportunities our vision is
that all individuals families and
communities Thrive because New Hampshire
is home to vibrant impactful nonprofits
and so we we did hear and we all
received this so I would say that they
hold on Harkin Phillips
hack and Phillips like a computer hack
thank you um Madam chair I just wanted
to weigh in quickly so I do provide uh
pro bono Council to a non-profit based
here in the state and I just wanted to
share with you that I do reference the
New Hampshire Center
um for non-profits uh regularly
throughout um
the formation process for other
non-profits as well as continuing on an
annual basis I refer back to their best
practice documents specifically for the
com conflict of interest policies that
both of
the nonprofits I help with um
kind of refer back to in their own
policy making decisions because the
center of
um
for non-profits here in New Hampshire is
known as kind of a national leader in
terms of providing that conflict of
interest Forward Thinking policy and I
know that the state of New Hampshire is
also recognized for being ahead of the
curve in the new non-profit sector
across this country in terms of you know
having those forward-thinking ideas
about keeping conflicts at the Forefront
of nonprofit management
so I would just like to throw in my two
cents about how I do believe that this
is a worthy organization to consider you
know putting on the commission moving
forward
thank you
represent fellows um yes I would just
like to add that I think it's important
to represent the Charities we have
somebody whose perspective covers the
Charities that are currently
participating in receiving money from
from the gaming and those who are maybe
would like to and are not able to
because there is certainly just a
limited number of slots so I think this
organization can
make sure that we get a perspective that
covers the a wider range of the charity
representative spilsbury are you okay
thank you madam chair I would just note
that the effect of the amendment would
be to change the composition of the
commission from an odd numbered 13 to an
even number 12. and I believe that's
generally not what we try to do
also I think the intent of the bill is
to find representatives of Charities
rather than representatives of
okay uh represent I saw Ames over here I
think did you
I think there there does seem to be a
void a uh Omission in this uh in the
bill
that this amendment
bills and that is uh no it's not there's
no designation of who will choose
the representative of the Facility
Owners and who will choose the
representatives of charitable gaming
Charities just completely left out
and uh
I think correcting that is uh probably
quite important in terms of uh getting
this off the ground
representative fellows said that she
thought it might delay the startup
because of the
absence of Direction on that issue and
uh she may be well be right although I'd
be happy to be corrected by any member
here who has more information on that
point uh if if it is uh if if it is an
Omission that matters then we should
address it
representative elberger thank you madam
chair I agree with representative
spilsbury about the notion of having a
charity rather than an organization that
consults to Charities but if you look at
the wording it says one member chosen by
the New Hampshire Center
for non-profits
and I think that uh
number one nobody was named as the
appointing authority for that member or
members at that time
and this group is much more likely to
have an idea of
what charities might be or charity or
Charities might be an appropriate one to
name rather than leaving it to some
unknown person and who may not know
anything about the charitable
the comments on the amendment I'm
looking around makeup representative
Doucette
point is well taken but but again if
we're talking about being concerned
about an unknown entity assigning this
is an unknown entity and I'm not
challenging their validity their mission
their statement what they do for work
but to to have someone something put in
front of us at the 11th hour here
um and I participated in the
subcommittee along with representative
Ames
it was the vision of that subcommittee
to have the Charities the people that
have got the dirt under their
fingernails for years
getting to us to where we are in the
charitable gaming model that we have at
present
um I'm sorry I have a real hard time and
it's probably a very valuable
component here
but I I can't with good conscience vote
to give an entity that I know absolutely
nothing about
appointment Authority in a commission
just it doesn't make logic to me
representative Platt I am treasurer of
Alliance site and hearing Foundation of
New Hampshire Inc
until the the testimony of the other day
I've never heard of this group so
they're not well known among the
Charities uh very at all
I've always thought
they should be more outward ranging but
they are the nuts and bolts behind the
Charities
um
what we've got now is I believe that the
house clerk is going to be responsible
to figure out
who would represent the Facility Owners
and who would represent two Charities
when there is a very wide range of
charitable interests
and then of course also leaves out the
ones who are left out at this point who
haven't been able to get on the lists
um
it seems to me
preferable if we want to leave out the
ones who can't get on the lists
that it could be changed to
or
the New Hampshire charitable gaming
operators Association picking all three
but in that case
um
they would be picking the ones that will
most likely parrot but they're saying so
they won't be terribly helpful uh
probably I may be maligning the
but we do
um
we do need somebody that that can pick
in both of these entities and I think
that the solution of the New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators Association
for the facilities owners makes sense he
has been a facility operator I don't
think he is one at the moment but he
works directly I mean he is working for
the Facility Owners
um
and if you don't
haven't heard of the New Hampshire
Center for non-profits
um
I'm not sure who we'd
who we could substitute that would be
better at this than the house Clerk
which I think is the default mechanism
if they forgot we forgot to stick it
okay other final comments did you have
something else I'm not sure thank you
madam chair I'm not sure how to fit this
in if at all but again following up on
representative almie's comment it might
be useful to have one if there are going
to be two Charities to have one of them
be a current recipient within the
framework of the historical horse racing
and one who is not
comments on the amendment yes um
so I picked that particular organization
because that was the only one I had any
information from based on the testimony
that we received but does if if anyone
else has a
knows about another organization that
would be a better one to represent the
Charities I think that would be good but
I think it's important to get you know
Charities are not all in the same place
and some may want to join
and that may be part of the what should
be looked at you know should there be a
way to cover include more Charities or
not you know so that's
along with the fact that you we need to
identify who makes a choice
I certainly would be
able to have another organization if
okay any other comments on the amendment
yo yes I'm sorry I missed you no thank
you go ahead please yes mainly for the
chair it does seem like
um bills that have commissions should
have appointments
and who does the appointing and this
bill doesn't for certain positions so is
that something we really should
straighten out as a committee before we
take you know the next step and then
also to confirm is the default always
the clerk or are there other options
um again though I think to have a clean
bill go forward
it would seem worthwhile to State
exactly how you know the other
other comments on the amendment
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
roll and the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment
uh thank you madam chair
representation
no
Representative ulery no representative
just said no representative spilsbury
now representative snow Representative
naughter no representative sodi nope
representative orrs
no Representative rolesfoot no uh
representative
yes representative Ames yes
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
hacken Phillips yes representative
fellows yes representative Bolton yes
represent alberger yes representative
Lloyd yes representative yes and the
chair
no the vote is uh 10 10 and the
uh Amendment 1517 fails are there any
other amendments on Senate bill 51.
seeing none down the motion before us
will be on the ought to pass motion of
the original Senate Bill 51. uh that was
moved by representative janikin did you
um
no I think um I think we're good my
comments from the initial
uh Bill moving on to pass still stand
other comments from the committee on the
ought to pass motion representative ores
did you uh want to say anything or are
you good okay uh represent all me
thank you this puts me in somewhat a
dilemma because we are issuing as a
final vote oh no it is early but it will
be going to a committee which is only
looking at the finances so we can't uh
get the policy changed which is flawed
um and you say it's coming out of left
field but it came out of left field
because we only heard this bill last
week
and we hadn't had a chance to discuss it
among ourselves yet
um
so
and I hadn't realized that a lot of
people didn't know what the center for
New Hampshire nonprofits is they have
quite an illustrious board I just looked
it up
but
um
we do have the moratorium
extension which is the only moratorium
extension that the Senate and the
governor are likely to accept
oh sorry
so I guess I will vote for it but I
would like to see our Amendment try to
be defended on the floor once we've
managed to recruit a few more people who
know what the center for nonprofits is
thank you
thank you uh other comments from the
committee members on ought to pass
motion
I will vote for this
um
and do so recognizing that I wish
that were slightly improved on a couple
of points not all of which have been
mentioned here but uh I think that it's
important that we go ahead with this
bill is it an important issue that this
commission will be addressing and
um
uh it's an issue that's Dynamic it's
moving there's actions that we're all
being asked to take on this bill and
that bill that relate to charitable
gaming
we need uh we need a group that's
charged with the responsibility of
looking at the whole and uh and uh
sorting it out uh in an intelligent and
useful way for all of us
and then on the particular problem of
appointments
um it is the fact that this bill will go
if it
passes on the floor which I hope it will
to the finance committee as a second
committee for review and it is a reality
much as some of us may want to wish it
were not that second committee is
although charged with a narrow charge to
focus on in the case of Finance
Financial issues I can guarantee you
that the finance committee is not always
huge to that
Narrow Path and that um
that if there's an issue like the one
we've been discussing here about who's
going to appoint to these positions
that it would not surprise me if the uh
if that issue uh found if a way
were to be found to resolve that issue
in the course of its uh Passage through
the house for that second committee
review so that's where I stand thank you
comments on the ought to pass motion
representative Stringham yes thank you
very much as a member of the finance
committee I'm shocked to hear what you
said
but uh you know I I I would encourage
the group if there is a floor amendment
that every that both parties feel is uh
uh creates a stronger Bill uh you know
by all means I hope we we go forward
with that it does certainly seem to make
sense to have uh the issue of whether
there's 13 or 12 members finalized as
well as uh who selects all the members
but obviously this is a very important
bill and I'd sure like the numbers to be
the only issue that there's any
disagreement about should it reach
representative Ames did you have
anything else to add
just checking I'm just looking for the
the red lights
um okay if there's no more comments then
we will now take uh the role the clerk
will call the role on the ought to pass
thank you madam chair I shall do so uh
representative why do I have so much
trouble with your last name again
we'll have a practice session later yes
okay representative uluri yes
representative Doucet yes representative
yes representative plett votes yes
representative naughter yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative roseford yes
representative Army
representative Ames yes yes reps of
Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Hagen Phillips yes yes representative
yes representative Lloyd yes
representative Smith
let's ringham
yes and the chair
yes the vote is twenty to zero
but if there's going to be a floor
Amendment
well uh well
either way it can't go on consent
calendar quickly if I'm wrong
Representatives only um but because it
has an FN and it is a second committee
bill it would not go on consent make
sense
okay all right the vote being 20-0 as
ought to pass it will go on the regular
calendar we will now close the exact
session on Senate bill 51. it's more of
a point yes
I thought I was hearing that it might be
able to be amended in finance anyway
which would mean there might not have to
be a floor amendment I mean so there's a
choice
yeah yeah people can decide which way
they want to go but it absolutely is
supposed to go to finance according to
the clerk yes thank you
okay
we will now we're just going to
numerical order with things that we're
ready for
um we will open up the executive session
on Senate Bill 104
and the chair recognizes representative
Doucette for a motion thank you madam
chair I move inexperienced to legislate
on SB 104.
is there a second second uh
representative elberger seconds uh
representative could you speak to your
motion certainly thank you madam chair
um although the intent of the
legislation as it was explained to us in
testimony from its prime sponsor is uh
we can all agree uh there's a need for
those scholarships for the Community
College this particular vehicle with
with the flaws in the in the legislation
itself
um
the way by which the funds are raised
the fact that it will
the testimony we heard will impact our
charitable uh Charities that get
serviced through a charitable gaming
model at present
um
basically the bill needs a lot of work
we can revisit this in the future but we
shouldn't jump into the deep end of the
pool
on big gaming at this point Thank you
madam chair
other comments from the committee and
for the record I am involved in the
charitable gaming industry just want to
make sure everyone knows that
wow okay see none the clerk will call
the roll
I should say I also am a recipient as a
charitable gaming a a charitable
organization before I call the role
going through the role of itl
Representative genegian yes represent uh
Ellery this is an itl representative
Doucette yes representative spilsbury
yes representative yes representative
Heinz
I haven't updated my sheet I can't keep
well I don't I'll embarrass myself once
okay uh representative Nutter yes
representative sodi yes represent orrs
yes representative yes representative
Army
representative Ames represents
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative hicken Phillips
yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
yes representative Lloyd yes
representative Smith
uh swingham yes
and the chair
yes okay the vote is 20 to zero Ikea
okay the vote being twenty to zero this
could go on consent calendar
you cannot because it have an FNA right
okay so it cannot go in consent okay so
this will go on the regular calendar uh
with the vote being 20-0 the itl motion
passes and will close the executive
while we're organizing ourselves anyone
here for Senate Bill 112 uh we are
scheduling a work session next Wednesday
around 9 30 in the morning so if you're
here for that bill please join us for
I honestly can't remember what I sent to
Karen it's somewhere around 9 30. I
can't remember though
we will now open up the hearing uh the
executive session on Senate Bill 119
which has to do with criminal background
checks for charitable games of chance
licensed applicants and again for the
record I am part of that industry and
the chair recognizes representative
janigan for motion thank you madam chair
I move ought to pass on SB 119. is there
representative software seconds
excellent
um
all right that's the other hands up but
uh representative janaian would you like
to speak to your motion yes thank you
madam chair
yeah this is uh this is a very simple
bill
um it's a common sense bill that would
eliminate unnecessary background checks
for those who are not intimately
involved in in the game of chance and so
therefore it will eliminate background
representative oh me
yes we had a Amendment introduced to us
uh from Senator Susie by Senator
Rosenwald on which solves a related part
of this problem of of bingo game
attendance
on and that was to increase the amount
of money that the Charities are allowed
to reimburse uh their volunteers who are
all volunteers
when they are doing the work that is
required by our law to be done to make
the bingo games work
and from 25
for expenses that they've incurred to
come to that game and and helps out the
chairs and everything on and on to fifty
dollars
and that
um they believe will
increase the ability of people who need
babysitters who are coming from a little
distance and are going to have to miss
dinner if they
don't have enough money to pay for
for a meal on the way in
um
that it allows them to have the
volunteers to have more bingo games
we have been regarding Bingo as a dying
industry but this is Apparently one of
the problems that inflation has caught
up
with their ability to attract the
volunteers
and on it was introduced to us and a
number of us wanted to be able to add it
on to this bill they thought that the
rest of the Senate would be Senator
Rosenwald thought that the rest of the
Senate would be willing to go along with
that but we don't have anything from the
rest of the senate about it
just a friendly reminder I right now
we're doing the ought to pass motion on
Cinema 119. do we have an amendment that
someone wants to move do we have an
amendment all the only amendment we have
at the moment and I'd hoped that we'd be
able to discuss whether we were going to
do this today or not on is
um the one from Senator Susie usually
when we have work sessions we talk about
the Amendments we've been given and then
we go and and vote on them the next week
after we've redone the amendments but
um the way we're doing it now we don't
have the ability to do that I'm going to
ask a parliamentary question to see if
anyone has an answer on this and that is
um
if Senator Susie did an amendment can we
just use that Amendment if someone wants
to move that amount I don't believe that
we can it's a a senate amendment number
we have to have our own amendment number
to pass it okay
there's a gentleman way in the back
there okay if you're answering the
Parliamentary question otherwise this is
not a public hearing this is an exact
session
it's on the wrong bill
oh
thank you sir
um all right let's take a I'm going to
take a moment to read through again
[Music]
it's amending the same section
s it's mending the section after the
and she oh we're on 119. oh no I could
not understand why you were were going
backwards again
I do apologize it's sir thank you I just
want to be clear that because if I start
opening up for public testimony then we
have a different different situation
here so but thank you for that we
appreciate the clarification okay so we
are on set up at 119 and you've skipped
and we don't have an amendment we did
Skip some stuff because we we're just
not ready I mentioned 112 which was the
next numerical one
we're gonna do a work session so now
we're on 119 the motion made by
representative genegian second but
representative Southworth was to ought
to pass
at the moment I don't have any
amendments before me that made by the
house
so we're now discussing the ought to
pass motion on Senate Bill 119 is there
any other comments on that
representative Stringham
okay
rep I'm sorry representative South
Florida thank you for being able to do
that
sense of changes so I certainly support
it
excellent seeing more no more hands up I
will now have the clerk call the roll
Senate Bill 119
ought to pass thank you madam chair and
I appreciate the time that took uh went
by so I could get the sheets in good
form
uh going on uh representativeian
yes representative uluri yes
representative this set yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative plattvotes yes
representative naughter yes
representative sodi yes representative
orrs yes representative roseford yes
represent Almy represent Ames
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representative hicken
Phillips yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Lloyd yes
representative Stringham yes in the
chair
no this bill with 20 to zero it does an
FN on it but it may be eligible for
consent calendar because it does not go
to a second committee I well does anyone
have an objection calendar
okay well we'll see if we can and we'll
Madam chair I move the adoption I gotta
open it up first
all right I just want to make sure
you're ready so we are now opening up
the executive session on Senate Bill 139
whoops relative to the price of Lucky
Seven tickets uh and the chair
recognizes representative
platform ocean yes I moved to uh ought
to pass with an amendment and I want to
introduce amendment number
1439h which I shall pass around let's
let's be sure we get a second on the
ought to pass
is there a second on ought to pass okay
second by representative Almy and now it
is open to your Amendment would you like
to pass out that Amendment and explain
it to us yes
I get my hands on it again
here it is
the amendment uh we heard testimony uh
when we heard this bill that one or two
people were happy with the ten dollar
limit but a lot of people got nervous
about that and wouldn't didn't want to
make it more than two dollars uh on
Lucky Seven tickets uh because they're
afraid of opening them up to opening up
to other organizations and killing the
people who do the Bingo and Lucky Seven
together so this amendment simply
changes the ten dollars
two two dollars when sold in a dispenser
still one dollar in paper form but two
okay representative Platt moods
Amendment 2023
1439 H is their second on the amendment
representative fellows
uh any uh
for the record I am in the charitable
gaming industry um just so you know
um
any other comments yes representative
fellows so um what we heard in what what
I picked up from the testimony was that
for the Charities that operate Bingo the
problem with having
um ten dollars as a wager meant that the
prize would be very could possibly be
very high and that they wouldn't have
that much money cash on hand to pay it
out so that that was another part of the
reason
other comments
seeing none the clerk will call the role
uh
and this is on Senate bill
about the Senate Bill itself I got it
right just checking double checking uh
representative uh
thank you madam chair representative yes
representative ulery
thank you
I suppose so
thank you for the enthusiasm
representative set yes representative
spilsbury yes representative plattvotes
yes representative naughter yes
representative sodi yes representative
orrs yes representative yes
representative Army representative Ames
yes Roseville Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes representative
hicken Phillips yes representative
fellows yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative leapley
now Lloyd
not a problem uh yes please
representative Stringham yes in the
chair yes 20-0 on the amendment okay
with 20-0 the amendment passes so now
the motion before us is uh ought to pass
as amended by
1439 H and the clerk will call the roll
is there any discussion by the way I
okay
um yes uh on Bill 139 ought to pass as
amended I asked for the vote of
representation
yes representative ulery
yes representative Doucette yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative Platt bills yes
representative naughter yes yes
represent Saudi yeah yes represent ores
yes representative roseford yes
representative Army represent Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representative hicken
Phillips yes representative fellows yes
representative uh Bolton yes
representative yes representative Lloyd
yes they caught myself
uh representative Stringham yes and the
chair yes 20-0 is the outcome okay the
vote being 20-0 on ought to pass as
amended the motion carries now I think
this could go on consent anyone opposed
to it going on consent
okay
we will now close the executive session
on Senate bill 139.
Browning and paper here
next
foreign
the exec session on Senate Bill 191
relative Road total registration
surcharges for electric vehicles and the
chair recognizes representative
spilsbury for a motion thank you madam
chair I move retain on HB 191. excuse me
SB 191. is there a second
oh representative soti seconds it uh
would you care to speak to your motion
yes thank you madam chair
I think that there's a broad consensus
that there's a genuine problem to solve
and that is how will electric vehicles
contribute to the maintenance of roads
and bridges in the state of New
Hampshire
but there's a wide variety of potential
ways of doing that
and each one represents a bit of a
conundrum
so this is a a classic bill that really
deserves more attention
then we can give it this season
I would also note that uh
I was a co-sponsor on HP 456
which was referred to house Public Works
and highways and that bill has been
retained by Public Works
the purpose of that bill is to address
the very same problem in an entirely
different way by looking at the
potential of taxing the charging
activity
so this bill I think
deserves the time possibly even some
coordination with one or more other
committees to come up with a solution
comments representative Olney
study committee I believe it is that
went from the house to the Senate
to
to continue the study that was being
done last year but in the second year
commit study committees don't get much
done
um on this
uh maybe someone else remembers better
the numbers but on
we need that kind of study
and as you said we need it in between
different
um people from
it could be environment and agriculture
or natural resources it could be uh
on but it's something that we was set up
two terms ago and then we had the covid
problems and then one term ago and
um it ended up as I recall meeting once
or twice and not getting the work done
and
and then this term going forward to the
Senate and
Senator Waters thought that they were
going to pass it but
I was told that the Senate was retaining
it to see what we do with this effort of
theirs
and I would very much like to not retain
this bill while we find out
where we are with the Senate on that
because we've been trying to work on
this issue for 10 years and the
situation gets worse and worse for
transportation and we haven't done
anything yet and this is regarded as a
kind of stop Gap measure to help the
bleeding and stop having to take Finance
having to take money out of the general
fund to pay for transportation
um
so since we have the time it is not an
early Bill
we could retain it until next week while
the chair
tries to find out what's happening in
the Senate
or the vice chair
let's see if the representatives can has
finished her remarks okay representative
represent Alma used the word retain till
next week I don't think that's retained
I think we just continue the hearing
continue the hearing
yeah
no um
we we now have a motion before us which
we will need to vote on and I will just
make a comment what I heard in this is
obviously a very very important topic we
know many committees and many
commissions have been looking at this
issue for many years and they have not
been able to come up with a solution
I don't think we're gonna we have the
all of the information we need I don't
think we have the time that we need to
do this Justice at this time so I do
believe that retained motion is
appropriate but we'll see where the vote
goes and we'll go from there
uh first I need to say that um
that I have electric vehicles and uh so
I'm going to be voting speaking and
voting on this bill
um and that needs to be understood
that's my obligation to say that and
then I will be supporting the
retain motion
um I think that uh
it's a complicated issue and if we can
make progress on this in this committee
let's do so
um and either gain Clarity on the
particular proposal that's before us or
adjust it which we can do over the
course of the next several months so
I'll be supporting this
representative ulrey
thank you madam chair uh correct me if
I'm wrong but it's my understanding that
when a bill is retained by committee
that doesn't necessarily mean nothing
happens it just merely means we're
maintaining possession of the bill
through the remainder of this year
through the summer and into January and
even in January we can continue work
sessions mixed in with our regular work
if we have any
right
um
so it's not really
putting it aside it's just
think main maintaining possession of the
bill so we can work on it is that
correct
absolutely we can start working on a we
can work on a retained Bill anytime we
want we couldn't after we get through
some of our deadlines and start working
on it this spring or we could wait to
the fall any individual member of this
committee can certainly keep working on
it with all stakeholders and for the
record I want to be an electric vehicle
owner
okay who else we have over here
representative homie I just want to
correct something the retained bills
have to be voted on by late October I
believe it is and then they go to the
floor and we lose control over it at
that point it goes to the floor and it
and it can go to the floor as referred
to interim study which means we put it
off for yet another year
on and I mean and if that causes the
and and uh refuse the commission then
we've got a real problem but
um there is a uh the reason Foundation
which reached out to me and which is
working with with
um
legislators legislatures in other parts
of this country on this issue which had
never reached out to New Hampshire
before and
um for some reason reason former
representative sumsitch with whom I
disagreed on this quite a lot uh told
them to talk to me
so I have now sent that to Waters and
can can send it to the committee too but
there is an experiment which he this guy
is very fond of that's original that's
in Virginia right now that's just
started so but the problem is every year
we're getting further behind on the
okay other comments representative
elberger thank you madam chair
um I disagree with several of my
colleagues here I don't see this as a
very difficult challenging bill
it's one that simply says that we're
asking electric vehicle owners to pay
for the use of the roads that they use
and they are not paying for them through
a gas tax I don't see this as
complicated so I will be voting against
retaining
representative orrs and I'm sorry I
missed you we'll go to your neck thank
you madam chair so I tend to agree with
representative all me I think we've
kicked this can down the road forever I
think I don't see it as very difficult
either it's like I'm not sure why we're
I'm all in favor of a hundred dollars on
the electric vehicles or two hundred
dollars or three hundred dollars the
road you know the roads got to be
repaired I don't like driving through
potholes either so thank you
representative janigan
thank you madam chair well I'll I'll
give you another reason why you may want
to retain it and that is the 20
that would go to the state to build out
infrastructure
really doesn't make sense we didn't the
state didn't build out gasoline stations
I don't believe the state should be
building out uh charging stations
however I'm not I want to retain it for
that reason but off also for the reason
it is complex as a member of Public
Works and highways seven years ago and I
know prior to then this bill comes up or
this type of Bill comes up in in public
works and highways every single year
um they have not found a solution to it
yet
that and we do need to find one and
maybe that does rest I think as
representative spilsbury may have said
you know at some point it'd be nice if
we could charge just like we charge the
gas tax at the gas station charge an
electric tax potentially at the charging
station once we figure out how to do
that but anyways this is a complex bill
it's not going to be solved in the next
week or two it has some flaws so it
shouldn't be passed as is so I would say
we need to retain at this point thank
you
other comments representative fellows I
I think it's about time that we send
this to the Full House and let them vote
on it and
um I I do see that 20 percent
can be up to 20 can be retained by
Transportation but it's up to so it
doesn't mean that they have to hold on
other comments from Members
representative elberger
thank you madam chair
um
one of the advantages that an electric
car owner can be to charge their
vehicles at home if they have power that
work that works for that and we can't go
into people's homes and say tell us what
percentage of your electric bill is
related to charging your car and we're
going to tax you on that so we can't
easily say that well we can do the a
parallel with the gas tax
on an electrical
charging setup so I I that doesn't make
sense to me and I again reiterate
and let's ask the electric vehicle
owners who have not been paying for any
kind of support of the roads for as long
as electric vehicles have been used in
this state let's ask them to pay their
Fair shift
representative
thank you madam chair you raise a good
point I mean that that is a problem
however that's that what that's one of
the things that makes this so complex
because what about all the Massachusetts
uh drivers that are coming up Route 95
Route 93 and Route 3 every single day
and especially on the weekends and
holidays they won't they're not they're
not paying anything so but if we could
charge them at charging stations at
least out of state and it's it's not
going to all follow New Hampshire
drivers I'm not saying that's the
complete solution it's not that's why
it's complex but um again I think retain
is in order
representative Ames did you want to
comment any further
okay uh anyone else would like to
comment
okay the motion before us is retain
Senate Bill 191 and the clerk will call
the roll on retain
thank you madam chair
represent genegian yes represent O'Leary
representative set yes representative
spilsbury yes representative yes
representative of an otter yes
representative sorry yes representative
orrs yes representative yes
representative Army
no
um you'll never disqualified on my book
uh representative Ames yes
representative uh representative
Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes
representation uh haken Phillips
yes
perhaps her fellows no
representative Bolton no
no
representative Lloyd yes
representative uh Stringham no
and the chair
yes the vote is 15 to 5.
retained okay so that means we're not
reporting it to calendar we're just
going to retain it in committee and we
will schedule work on that at the
appropriate time and of course
representative all me we want you part
okay
with that we have retained Senate Bill
191 and we will close the executive
session on that
anymore
and this will be the last part of the
day
oh
yeah
okay which one is 192. okay
okay we will now open the executive
session on Senate Bill 192 relative to
the hours that Lucky 7 tickets may be
sold and the chair recognizes
representative Rochford for a motion
thank you madam chair I move uh ought to
pass on Senate bill 192. is there a
second
uh representative all me seconds that
for the record I am involved in the
turbo gaming industry representative
Roche would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair uh
Senate Bill 192 really is a you know for
lack of a better term it's uh it's a
cleanup bill I mean it it it it matches
Uh current law with when bingo games can
operate
um with Lucky 7 tickets we heard
testimony that uh a number of bingo uh
facilities have run two games multiple
games during the day and they start
early in the morning
um but the way the law is currently
written the Lucky Seven ticket sales are
uh limited somewhat are quite quite
limited and therefore the Charities that
that could be benefiting fully are not
benefiting fully from their sale so uh I
think it just makes sense to match that
with the current Bingo laws
representable me
if I could the current law is that they
aren't allowed to do this before I
forget whether it's noon or 1 pm noon on
but
the actual situation
for a long time was that they were doing
it
and they were doing a game in the
morning and a game in the afternoon and
before the game started people would
come in and have coffee and socialize uh
and that's when they were buying the
Lucky Seven tickets
and
there was a restructuring at Lottery
and the
current head of
of charitable gaming which was brought
into lot lottery
on at the time was
um
found that this was in rules
and moved last year to put it into law
just so people would see it and what
that resulted in was a number of
normal bingo games being uh cut in half
in places that had been doing this all
along I don't understand why we ever
said Bingo should go to 1am I can't
imagine it ever has but
um we don't want to have to amend that
for this purpose but
um those Charities are generally I think
the the smaller ones because they have a
great deal of socialization going on
during the day
particularly in the morning hours and
they're losing more than half of their
revenue actually
because of this
so
other comments on the ought to pass
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
rule thank you madam chair
uh this is on to pass on 192 represent
genegian yes
represent ulery yes representative
Doucet yes representative yes
representative yes representative
naughter yes representi yes represent
orrs yes representative yes represent
Almy yes representative Ames
weapons of the Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
hicken Phillips yes representative
fellow fellows 15. okay representative
Bolton yes represent elberger yes
representative uh Lloyd yes
representative Stringham
yes in the chair yes the vote is 20-0
vote being 20-0 the ought to pass motion
uh on SB 192 passes and uh it is an FN
bill I don't know exactly why uh but we
will request it to be on consent
calendar unless anyone disagrees nope
then we'll we'll request that and we'll
now close the executive session on
the um we have listed Senate Bill 260 on
the possible executive session
um we just heard this bill today there
is a new fairly new rule in the house
that says that is as long as the chair
and the ranking member agree we can
infect exec a bill on the same day as
the hearing and we have agreed that uh
having the exact session on Senate Bill
260 does make sense today so we'll be
okay we will now open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 260 relative to
deductions under the business profits
tax for compensation of members and
owners and the chair will recognize
representative and the chair will
okay Madam chair on this bill motion oh
oh I I make uh I move on itl on SB 260.
is there a second
representative ellberger sentence okay
now please speak to your motion
anyway on
the intent of this bill is well
intentioned
but I guess I said that wrong but anyway
uh
but in fact by
duplicating
almost duplicating the language that
already exists in the law and on
it
creates a situation in which there could
be major confusion on in
in the
the
on
rules applied by dra
and in the auditing process
and
um
the committee believes that
that
adding the word
custom well maybe I should put in that
part about guard rails but but adding
the word customary
and repeat
the reasonable compensation
law was revamped
on
with me
by the ways and means committees
all right however many years ago it was
now
um
2012 on to make it
compensation of the compensation discuss
deductions fair and reasonable
for all uh Partnerships and
proprietorships and
um
the addition of the word customary
without guard guard rails in a separate
section
I'm going to work on this but in a
separate section does
um
for a number of accountants and lawyers
consulted create confusion
uh
in the law and
that is why I think that we ought to
thank you and for the record I do pay
business profits tax
um representative yes we heard testimony
from dra that this is not necessary and
it's harmful because it adds another
word which is confusion when you do
something like that people think there's
something new there and there isn't so
just wind up confusing people
other comments from the committee on the
itl motion on Senate Bill 260
representative janigan
thank you madam chair yes just want to
say briefly I will I am also on itl on
this I reached out to
um CPA and also a um
a foundation that studies tax policy and
both of them were confused with the
wording and didn't see the uh the point
so thank you
other comments from the committee
representative almond did you have
something else to add
no okay so I have to clean up my
language that's okay that's okay I think
we can all work on that
um okay uh if there's no other comments
then the clerk will call the roll itl on
Senate Bill 260. thank you madam chair
representativeian yes represent uluri
yes representative Doucette yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative yes representative
naughter yes representative yes
representative orrs yes representative
Rochford yes represent Army
representative Ames
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
haken Phillips yes representative
fellows yes representative Bolton yes
representative yes representative Lloyd
yes representative Stringham yes and the
chair yes that's 20-0 through itl
the vote being 20-0 the ital motion on
Senate Bill 260 passes it is an FN bill
I don't know we can request consent
with an itl that's the difference too
thank you so we'll try to put it on
consent unless the clerk has a problem
and we'll now close the executive
session on cinepol 260.
nice job guys wow so efficient uh so
prepared thank you um we obviously
skipped some bills that we didn't feel
like we were ready to do yet we have
some work sessions coming up so for
planning purposes we will meet again
next Wednesday I don't have the exact
times there will be uh some work
sessions and uh there's also oh there is
an amendment on Senate Bill 19 and we
will schedule
a hearing on that Amendment just to make
sure everyone gets to hear that and then
we'll have an exact session after that
and see what we can get done if we don't
get it all done then we will schedule
for the following Tuesday for any
remaining bills that we have for exec
session and we'll just keep chipping
away at our work as the best that we can
so thank you for our members for being
here our substitutes for being here we
appreciate your participation
representative Platt the amendment uh we
have to have a hearing on because it's
slightly different section but we're
extending the hours of bingo to 16 hours
uh 16 days rather so this would extend
Lucky Seven for the same 16 days but
it's because it's a different section of
the same law we have to have a public
I do have an amendment for Senate Bill
112 which on I in the hearing I heard
someone else talking about an amendment
too so I'm not sure mine should be
drafted by now but it hadn't come out
anyone who's interested in Senate Bill
112 please come to the work session if
if you have a specific idea for an
amendment please find a Committee Member
that you'd like to work on that with you
um this one we'll see if we can get it
done does create a dedicated fund for
breakage within the um
the bill itself is is talking about the
uh is meant to move money into the
problem gaming fund the problem gaming
fund at this point is
um controlled by a group that I just
found out about after I did the
amendment but that on the finance
committee sends money to the Council on
problem gaming but it is
so I need to go back now that there's
time and talk to lbao about okay is
there any kind of problem in creating a
dedicated fund that is
administratively attached to to Lottery
which they all of them are attached to
some department or other
um
and
on
that would would come from the fees
inside the lottery itself which is what
the bill is doing
but the idea was to try to of the of the
sponsor as I understand it was mostly to
try to to put more money into that
um that Council so that there would be
more uh work done on problem gaming
and the language that I I have so that
says that the purpose of the fund would
be to Pro to provide funding for
identification and treatment of problem
gamblers
so
I've I've got to look up the council for
problem game gaming and see whether it
has purpose or not
hopefully because we're not going to
have this until next Wednesday people
have time to really work on that so
please do that research if you can
though today we need to get our business
done for today so if you made a motion
please get me your blurb before you
leave
uh before we leave yes ugh uh is there a
music
foreign